programming throwdown episode 182 AI assisted coding take it away Jason hey everybody how's it going out there? How are you doing, Patrick? I am doing well. I like how you asked a non-existent audience how they're doing. I mean, the audience exists. They're just not live. Well, they'll be alive when they...
Programming Throwdown 第 182 期：AI 辅助编程。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好，外面怎么样？Patrick，你怎么样？我很好。我喜欢你问一个不存在的听众他们过得怎么样。我的意思是，听众是存在的，只是他们不是在直播。好吧，当他们……
Oh, never mind. I hope everyone's doing well. You can email us, even though it's like weeks later. But, um, so it's actually the day after father's day when we're recording this. So, uh, did you do anything yesterday for father's day? Uh, we did some, does some low key stuff. I don't know. I don't feel like it needs to be over the top. How about you?
哦，没关系。希望大家都过得好。你们可以给我们发邮件，尽管这已经是几周后的事了。但是，嗯，我们录制这期节目的时候其实是父亲节的第二天。那么，你昨天过父亲节了吗？嗯，我们做了一些比较低调的事情。我不知道，我觉得没必要搞得太隆重。你呢？
Yeah. I mean, pretty much the same. I mean, we just, uh, we, the soccer ball with the boys, just pretty, uh, pretty mundane stuff. Like I don't really do anything too crazy for Father's Day. Well, I feel like we should have had something more interesting to say. No, well, we're going to jump into getting an entry level job. So this is something that someone asked on Discord. This comes up very often in our pouring through down email and,
是啊。我的意思是，差不多一样。我们只是和孩子们踢了踢足球，非常平凡的事情。我真的没为父亲节做什么太疯狂的事。好吧，我觉得我们应该说点更有趣的事情。不，我们要开始讨论如何找一份入门级工作了。这是有人在 Discord 上问的问题。这在我们的 Programming Throwdown 邮件中经常出现，而且，
and I get a lot of messages on LinkedIn about this. For whatever reason, like LinkedIn is, uh, uh, the place where everyone wants to talk. I'll make a post on Twitter and get like 13 views. I don't know why but LinkedIn is just the place. I guess because we are work-related people talking about work-related stuff so that makes a lot of sense. So okay lots of folks are saying hey I'm having a hard time getting entry-level job. I have friends who are maybe a generation older than us and their kids have finished college and their kids can't get a job.
我在 LinkedIn 上也收到了很多关于这个的消息。不管出于什么原因，LinkedIn 似乎是每个人都想交流的地方。我在 Twitter 上发帖只有 13 次浏览。我不知道为什么，但 LinkedIn 就是那个地方。我想是因为我们都是与工作相关的人在谈论与工作相关的事情，所以这很有道理。好吧，很多人说，嘿，我很难找到入门级工作。我有朋友可能比我们大一代，他们的孩子大学毕业了，却找不到工作。
I know folks who have extremely respectable positions at companies in Silicon Valley and their kids went to very prestigious universities, got computer science degrees, sometimes even a master's degree, and can't get a job. And my first reaction is, well, why can't you get them a job at your company? I mean, you know, you're very distinguished and everything. And, you know, obviously I don't ask that because you know clearly they have tried that But but it really shows shows me and I think everyone that it's a very tough market. So let's just be frank It's it's a really difficult market out there
我认识一些在硅谷公司担任非常受人尊敬职位的人，他们的孩子上了非常著名的大学，拿到了计算机科学学位，有时甚至是硕士学位，却找不到工作。我的第一反应是，好吧，为什么不能让他们在你的公司找份工作呢？我的意思是，你知道，你非常杰出等等。而且，你知道，显然我不会那样问，因为很明显他们已经尝试过了。但这确实向我，我想也向所有人表明，这是一个非常艰难的市场。所以我们坦率地说，现在的市场真的很困难。
It's a difficult time to be looking for a job And so for folks who are just graduating you should just know that that this is a tough time And so that just recognizing are just graduating, you should just know that this is a tough time. And so that just recognizing that I think is important. And I have a bunch of ideas of suggestions, but Patrick, why don't you give me kind of your raw take on the situation that will jump in to help tips. Yeah. I mean, I think it's a, always a very nuanced question. So when I get asked this, not on social media,
现在找工作是一个困难时期。所以对于刚毕业的人来说，你应该知道这是一个艰难的时期。我认为认识到这一点很重要。我有一堆想法和建议，但 Patrick，你为什么不先谈谈你对这种情况的初步看法，然后我们再深入探讨帮助建议。是的，我的意思是，我认为这是一个非常微妙的问题。所以当被问到这个问题时，不是在社交媒体上，
but in like real life, you know, with that, no. What is that? I think that it can be a great many things. So, I mean, the university education systems, you know, do offer a great many degrees that people are asking for related to nominally computers or computer science or computer programming. Those jobs aren't always 100% aligned with the specific actual being employed at, you know, a Silicon Valley company or, you know, a major company doing pure sort of software engineering work. And it's not a trying to quibble about the words.
而是在现实生活中，你知道，那个，不。那是什么？我认为这可能有很多原因。我的意思是，大学教育系统确实提供了许多人们要求的与计算机、计算机科学或计算机编程相关的学位。这些工作并不总是与在硅谷公司或大型公司从事纯软件工程工作 100% 一致。这不是在玩文字游戏。
I just think the background and the education you're getting and the kind of classes can matter a lot. So if you're learning a lot about how computers at a conceptual level work and about administering computers, right? Then we're talking about something a little bit different. So I get a lot of people reach out, they get towards the end of their education,
我只是认为你的背景、所受的教育以及所上的课程可能非常重要。所以，如果你学了很多关于计算机在概念层面是如何工作的以及如何管理计算机的知识，对吧？那么我们谈论的就是有点不同的东西了。所以我有很多在教育快结束时联系我的人，
which is very difficult to help out, but get to the end of their education. And they've kind of realized this that, oh, what I want is actually like a programming job, but I didn't really take programming classes either because I didn't know, or because, you know, they were considered too difficult or I wasn't aligned with it.
这很难提供帮助，但他们到了教育的尽头。他们意识到，哦，我真正想要的是一份编程工作，但我并没有真正上过编程课，要么是因为我不知道，要么是因为，你知道，它们被认为太难了，或者我不适合。
It doesn't, you know, reason doesn't per se matter. So then they're trying to find like the sort of next best thing. And so they're looking at sort of like engineering project manager roles or related sort of like test roles or something that they feel is like the next best thing. SRE, Site Reliability Engineers, they're looking through the Google response. Now you would say like the AI response to like what do you do if you want to like work with or adjacent or get into programming but you don't have a programming degree. And for me that's really hard because
这，你知道，原因本身并不重要。所以他们试图寻找类似次优的选择。所以他们正在寻找类似工程项目经理的角色，或者相关的测试角色，或者他们觉得是次优选择的其他东西。SRE，站点可靠性工程师，他们正在查看 Google 的回复。现在你会说，比如 AI 对“如果你想从事编程工作或进入编程领域，但你没有编程学位该怎么办”的回复。对我来说，这真的很难，因为
I just don't know, like I work with those people sometimes but I don't have a programming degree. Um, and for me, that's really hard because I just don't know. Like I work with those people sometimes, but I don't, I'm not super familiar with their hiring process and what discriminates against, you know, well qualified and discriminate is wrong word there helps you decide it is the right word. You've been doing too much AI, too much AI work. It, it, to determine between, uh, you know, really well-qualified candidates and sort of the average candidate.
我只是不知道，比如我有时会和这些人一起工作，但我没有编程学位。嗯，对我来说，这真的很难，因为我只是不知道。比如我有时会和这些人一起工作，但我对他们的招聘流程不是很熟悉，也不知道什么能区分，你知道，合格的候选人——“区分”这个词用错了，应该是“帮助你决定”。你最近做太多 AI 工作了。它，它，用来确定，呃，你知道，真正合格的候选人和普通候选人之间的区别。
So I like it that other way, because I think that is sort of a separate problem. But for people who are trying to do like, I'll say programming high technical interviews for programming, technical positions, then yeah, it becomes sort of the same issue that propped up, you know, awhile ago with, you know, for getting into university, everybody's kind of figured out you need to understand how to code. You need to practice leak code style problems. You need to, like everyone got past that hurdle. I think Jason, like when you sort of joined Silicon Valley or when I did,
所以我喜欢那种方式，因为我认为这是一个单独的问题。但对于那些试图进行，我会说编程高技术面试以获得编程技术职位的人来说，那么是的，这变成了和之前出现的问题一样，你知道，很久以前，你知道，为了进入大学，每个人都弄清楚了你需要了解如何编码。你需要练习 LeetCode 风格的问题。你需要，就像每个人都跨过了那个障碍。我想 Jason，就像你加入硅谷时，或者我加入时，
you could still get a significant edge by practicing those style programming. Because most people didn't do it, didn't want to, or didn't know to do it. But I think that time is gone. And most people who are going to get close are going to have already know how to do that stuff. So it becomes, what do you do to distinguish yourself? And the thing you said, it's just a really, really,
你仍然可以通过练习那种风格的编程获得显著优势。因为大多数人没有这样做，不想这样做，或者不知道该这样做。但我认为那个时代已经过去了。大多数即将接近目标的人都已经知道如何做这些事情了。所以问题变成了，你做什么来让自己脱颖而出？而你刚才说的那件事，现在市场真的，真的，
really tight market right now. I mean, we've done this podcast long enough through time's thick and thin, I guess. And it's just a very tight market right now. And that makes it really, really hard, especially for entry level positions. Yeah, that's a great synopsis. No, that was awesome.
非常紧缩。我的意思是，我们做这个播客已经足够久了，经历了风风雨雨，我想。现在市场非常紧缩。这使得它真的，真的很难，尤其是对于入门级职位。是的，这是一个很好的总结。不，那太棒了。
I mean, I think, yeah, let me unpack that. I think, yeah, let me unpack that. So, the SRE IT cloud management, project management, these are areas that are super important. We both work with those folks, but we don't just frankly know that much about... I've never sat in an SRE interview panel or anything like that. So, um, so I really couldn't say, uh, also couldn't say much about that. Um, focusing on the software engineering, you
我的意思是，我想，是的，让我来拆解一下。我想，是的，让我来拆解一下。所以，SRE、IT 云管理、项目管理，这些领域非常重要。我们都与这些人一起工作，但坦率地说，我们对这些了解不多……我从未参加过 SRE 面试小组之类的。所以，嗯，所以我真的说不出什么，呃，也说不出太多关于那个的内容。嗯，专注于软件工程，你
brought up an interesting point. So, so yeah, just to recap. So I was like, I think I was like in 30th place or something on the top coder collegiate challenge. And that meant a lot. I mean, basically that, like, I could just put that on my resume and leave everything else blank and I could get interviews, all the top companies in 2009. Right. So, um, it was basically like a, like a contest and, um, basically like a contest and basically like a contest and the people who scored high
提出了一个有趣的观点。所以，所以是的，回顾一下。所以我想我当时在 TopCoder 大学生挑战赛中排名第 30 位左右。这意义重大。我的意思是，基本上，我可以把它写在简历上，把其他所有东西都留空，我就能在 2009 年获得所有顶级公司的面试机会。对吧？所以，嗯，它基本上就像一场比赛，而且，嗯，基本上就像一场比赛，而且，嗯，基本上就像一场比赛，在比赛中得分高的人
in that contest could that alone, it was like an SAT type thing. And I don't know if we really have that anymore. I think certainly the like talent piling into it, I don't keep up with that scene anymore, but you just don't hear about it as much. So I'm sure people are still out there doing competitive programming. And it is still helpful. I mean, I think it's almost seen as a,
仅凭这一点，就像 SAT 那样的东西。我不知道我们现在是否还有那种东西。我认为人才涌入其中，我不再关注那个圈子了，但你只是听到的少了。所以我相信人们仍然在进行竞技编程。而且它仍然有帮助。我的意思是，我认为它几乎被视为一种，
I mean, ranking could still matter, but it's almost seen as a, okay, and? Like, yes, yes, we agree you should have done that. Okay, and what next? Yeah, like in my case, you know, what I wanted to do was, you know, do advancements in AI. I didn't really want to be a systems engineer or, you know, make the database
我的意思是，排名可能仍然很重要，但它几乎被视为一种，“好吧，然后呢？”就像，是的，是的，我们同意你应该这样做。好吧，接下来呢？是的，就像在我的情况下，你知道，我想做的是，你知道，在 AI 方面取得进展。我真的不想成为一名系统工程师，或者，你知道，让数据库
at any of these companies faster. That just wasn't my goal. But it was kind of like an SAT or IQ test type thing. It's like, oh, you got the bullseye on top coder, so you must just be a good person to be in tech. And there really isn't anything kind of like that. If you want to, I'm gonna pick something different here on purpose, if you want to really work
在这些公司中运行得更快。那根本不是我的目标。但这有点像 SAT 或智商测试之类的东西。就像，哦，你在 TopCoder 上拿到了靶心，所以你一定是一个适合从事科技行业的好人。真的没有类似的东西。如果你想，我故意在这里选一个不同的东西，如果你想真正从事
on distributed databases, I mean, different here on purpose. Like if you want to really work on like distributed databases, like I mean there isn't like a thing you can really do like a top coder type thing to really just show everybody. And so one of my fears is that it will come down to like where did you go to college and full disclosure I went to went to a state college that wasn't even the flagship college of my state. I felt like I got a great education, but if you're going to go based off prestige,
分布式数据库工作，我的意思是，故意在这里选一个不同的东西。就像如果你想真正从事分布式数据库工作，我的意思是，没有你可以真正做的类似 TopCoder 的东西来向大家展示。所以我担心的是，它会归结为“你去了哪所大学”，顺便说一句，我上的是一所州立大学，甚至不是我所在州的旗舰大学。我觉得我接受了很好的教育，但如果你要根据声望来判断，
that definitely wouldn't have helped. But I do feel like, since the other thing about these things like Topcoder ander and hacker rank and all of that is, it's too easy to cheat now with these AI tools, which we're going to talk about in this podcast, but it's just too easy to cheat. And so it's kind of broken as a yardstick. Yeah, that's a great point. And I think of the kind of programming, like you mentioned, you can't get training in sort of building a distributed database and the AI assist isn't there. But for those, you know, leak code top coder problems, actually the training data sets
那肯定没有帮助。但我确实觉得，因为像 TopCoder、HackerRank 等等这些东西的另一件事是，现在用这些 AI 工具作弊太容易了，我们会在这个播客中讨论，但作弊太容易了。所以它作为衡量标准已经坏掉了。是的，这是一个很好的观点。而且我想到那种编程，就像你提到的，你无法通过培训来构建分布式数据库，而且 AI 辅助也不在那里。但对于那些，你知道，LeetCode TopCoder 问题，实际上训练数据集
are already incorporated into a lot of the AI. Yeah, I mean, another thing kind of related, a lot of people are saying they're getting auto rejected and stuff like that. I feel like the interview process, companies are pushing like return to office, but they're not making the interviews in person. I think they're trying to have it both ways.
已经整合到很多 AI 中了。是的，我的意思是，另一件相关的事情，很多人说他们被自动拒绝之类的。我觉得面试过程，公司在推动“重返办公室”，但他们没有进行面对面的面试。我认为他们试图两全其美。
It's like, we're gonna interview people over the internet so you don't have to pay for all these plane tickets. But then if we hire the person, we want them to come to our site. And I think what you end up with is a lot of cheating. I think that it's easier to cheat if you're on a Zoom call versus if you're right there with somebody. I mean, I'll pose this. Do you think that maybe really high skilled engineering is less important than it used to be? I don't think it's less important. I think it's, and when you say auto rejected, I think you, maybe we jumped it there. I think that was maybe the thing is, like right now, how would you tell how many people given big tech company, I don't want to name one because I don't want, I think they're
就像，我们要通过互联网面试人们，这样你就不用支付所有这些机票钱了。但如果我们雇佣了这个人，我们希望他们来到我们的现场。我认为你最终得到的是大量的作弊。我认为如果你在 Zoom 通话中，比你和某人面对面时更容易作弊。我的意思是，我提出这一点。你认为高技能工程是否比过去不那么重要了？我不认为它不那么重要。我认为它是，当你提到自动拒绝时，我想你，也许我们跳过了这一点。我想那可能就是问题所在，就像现在，你怎么知道一家大型科技公司有多少人，我不想点名，因为我不想，我认为它们
all kind of the same. If you were to insert whatever Fortune 500 company based in Silicon Valley. How would you find out how many actual people they're wanting to hire in the next 30 days or the next 60 days? Now I'm going to go to their website and I'm looking at their job posting. I'm telling you that's not that's uncorrelated. Right? That is not expressed to you their actual desire to bring in X number of candidates
都差不多。如果你要插入任何一家总部位于硅谷的财富 500 强公司。你怎么能找出他们在未来 30 天或 60 天内真正想雇佣多少人？现在我要去他们的网站，查看他们的招聘启事。我告诉你，那是不相关的。对吧？那并没有向你表达他们真正想在未来 60 天内引入 X 名候选人
on site for a job, you know, interview, uh, new hire processing in the next 60 days. Those posts stay up as like, uh, and I don't mean it in a negative connotation as like trawling nets to just look for super, super high quality candidates and then they'll make space. But if you say, Hey, I'm okay hiring zero people, but if someone really talented comes along, of course I'll, you know, want to talk to them. That is indistinguishable from, I have a desperate desire to hire a hundred new engineers in the next 60 days. But if you, if you think through now, like you're saying that the cheating, but
进行现场面试、新员工入职处理的愿望。这些帖子留着就像，呃，我不是贬义地指像拖网一样寻找超级、超级高质量的候选人，然后他们会腾出空间。但如果你说，嘿，我雇佣零个人也没关系，但如果有人才出现，我当然会，你知道，想和他们谈谈。这与“我迫切希望在未来 60 天内雇佣 100 名新工程师”是无法区分的。但如果你，如果你现在思考，就像你说的作弊，但
also from the company's side, the ability to leverage up recruiters to just talk to lots and lots of people and sort of do whatever grading ranking they want to do and talk to the top few, just looking for, you know, I'm casually just browsing, right? When you go to the store and you're like, I literally just want to walk around and look. It's hard for them to tell the difference between that. And like, I have, you know, $10,000 in my pocket and I'm burning to spend it in your store, right? Like from, from an interviewer interviewees perspective, it's very difficult to tell. And so part of it is that, and I think that those jobs, the
也从公司方面来看，利用招聘人员与大量的人交谈并进行他们想要的任何评分排名，并与前几名交谈的能力，只是寻找，你知道，我只是随便浏览，对吧？当你去商店时，你就像，我真的只是想走走看看。他们很难区分这一点。就像，我口袋里有 10,000 美元，我渴望在你的店里花掉它，对吧？从面试官和面试者的角度来看，很难区分。所以部分原因是这样，而且我认为那些工作，
desire to hire just isn't there. So really qualified engineers probably don't go through that process. They do occasionally have been, they don't have networks that process. They do occasionally happen. They don't have networks or coming out of a different industry or whatever. But the way I've seen a lot of that happens is you sort of directly already know someone and it sounds really harsh. Most it's sort of like that self, you self realism thing you got to do. Like when you're coming out of college, are you really going to distinguish yourself?
雇佣的愿望根本不存在。所以真正合格的工程师可能不会经历那个过程。他们偶尔会，他们没有那个过程的网络。他们偶尔会发生。他们没有网络，或者来自不同的行业等等。但我看到很多这种情况发生的方式是，你直接认识某人，这听起来真的很刺耳。大多数这有点像那种自我现实主义的事情，你必须做。就像当你刚从大学出来时，你真的会让自己脱颖而出吗？
Like if the industry is tight and some companies are laying off, you got to look like there are people coming out who are going to be more experienced than you for sure. So if you're all competing for speculative jobs, like a company is going to be really hard for you. Right. And that's not a criticism of you. It's a state of the market that probably I don't, I don't have a good suggestion. Like there's not getting involved with open source, you know, finding something
就像如果行业紧缩，一些公司在裁员，你必须看到肯定有比你更有经验的人出来。所以如果你都在竞争投机性的工作，就像一家公司对你来说会非常困难。对吧。这并不是对你的批评。这是市场状况，可能我没有，我没有好的建议。就像没有参与开源，你知道，在此期间找点事情做，找一个相邻的，就像找到某种方式继续磨练你的技能并建立你的简历是我能给出的最好的建议。但很不幸，我们不能作为行业对人们诚实，说，看，我们现在真的不太感兴趣。就像欢迎你申请，但我们真的不感兴趣。嗯，在那种对话中没有诚实的激励。是的，我的意思是，是的，这很有道理。
to do in the meantime, finding an adjacent, like finding some way to continue to hone your craft and build up your resume is sort of the best suggestion I can give. But it's, it's unfortunate that we can't be honest as industry with people and say, look, we're just not really that interested right now. Like you're welcome to apply, but we're really not interested. Um, there's not a incentive for honesty in that conversation. Yeah. I mean, yeah, that makes a ton of sense.
就像我们说的，如果他们不需要让你飞越半个国家或世界去面试，那么他们也没有任何利害关系，对吧？所以是的，这很有道理。好吧，所以我确实对刚从大学出来的人有一些建议。好的，所以首先，
Like, as we said, if they don't have to fly you halfway across the country or the world to do an interview, then they have really no skin in the game either, right? So yeah, that makes a ton of sense. Okay, so I do have a couple of suggestions for people coming out of college. All right, so first of all,
这就是本期节目的灵感来源之一，就是掌握最新的工具。所以，拥有最新的工具供你使用，熟练掌握它们，了解它们的局限性，所以这些聊天工具，我们现在会专门用一整期节目来讨论它，但是，但是它们，它们可能会非常自信地建议一些完全垃圾的东西。比如，嗯，哦，你知道，你有这个问题。好吧，你为什么不在这里为单元测试写一个单元测试呢？我为你写了一个。它测试单元测试
and that's why that was one of the inspirations of this episode, is get on board with the latest tools. So, have the latest tools at your disposal, be adept at them, understand kind of what the limitations are, so these chat tools tools and we'll dedicate a whole show to it right now, but, but they, they might suggest something very confidently that is total garbage. Like, um, Oh, you know, you have this problem. Well, why don't you like write a unit test for the unit test here? I wrote one for you. It tests the unit test
然后你仍然有你之前拥有的所有相同的问题。就像它实际上什么都没做。嗯，所以就像，你知道，当你熟练使用这些工具时，就像任何工具一样，你会发现它哪里好，哪里不好，它如何帮助你，它如何不帮助你，你就会领先一步。我认为挑战之一，假设 Patrick 和我都很忙，你知道，我们，你知道，我必须整个周末踢足球，然后我有一份日常工作，我还在做播客。所以我没有那么多时间去，你知道，
and then you still have all the same problems you had before. Like it didn't actually do anything. Um, so like, you know, as you get adept with these tools, just like any tool, you're going to find where it's good, where it's not good, how it's helping you, how it's not helping and you'll be kind of ahead. I think one of the challenges, let's say that Patrick and I have is we're very busy, you know, we, you know, I have to spend all weekend kicking a soccer ball and then I have a day job and I'm doing the podcast. And so I don't have as much time to, you know,
看看处于最前沿的东西，就像我想要的那样，对吧？作为一个刚从大学出来的人，你拥有一件事就是大量的时间来学习他们在大学里没有教你的所有东西，因为在你四年前开始上大学时，它们甚至还没有被发明出来。所以我肯定会深入研究所有这些。我认为关于自动拒绝，
look at what is on the bleeding edge as I would like, right? And as someone who's coming out of college, that's one thing you have is a ton of time to learn all the things they didn't teach you in college because they weren't even invented when you started college four years ago. So I would definitely dive into all of that. I think that with respect to the auto rejection,
如果你被自动拒绝了，按照 Patrick 的观点，很大程度上是因为老实说，根本就没有工作，对吧？所以他们正在寻找 30 年的经验，就像你根本不会有那样，或者有，是的，寻找一些非常具体的东西，就像没有刚从大学出来的人真正拥有的那样，对吧？所以它真的不是一个入门级的职位，即使描述上可能这么说。嗯，但是，呃，嗯，嗯，哦，是的，但是，但是你可以做的是，是，呃，嗯，把
if you're getting automatically rejected, to Patrick's point, a lot of that is because there really was never a job, right to be honest right and so they're looking for 30 years of experience and like you're just not gonna have that or there's yeah looking for something incredibly specific that like no one coming out of college actually has right and so it's not really a position for entry level, even though it might say so on the description. Um, but, uh, um, um, oh yeah, but, but what you can do is, is, uh, um, put
简历上正确的东西，以某种方式突出那些你觉得有需求的特定东西。所以就像很多公司，我猜他们对 DevX 感兴趣。就像如果你能让你的工程师快 100 倍，他们就在，我的意思是，我编造了 100，但你知道，快 10 倍，他们的工程师在过去两年里快了 1.5 倍。好吧，那里有改进的空间，他们会想要对，谁是拥有所有这些工具的人感兴趣？所以就像拥有一份简历，击中很多
the right things on your resume to kind of like highlight those specific things that you feel like are in demand. So like a lot of companies, my guess is are interested in dev X. Like if you can make your engineers a hundred X faster and they're at, I mean, I made up the hundred, but you know, it's a 10 X faster and their engineers are going 1.5 X faster in the past two years. Well, and there's like a room for improvement there and they're gonna wanna be interested in like, who are the people who have all those tools? So like having like a resume that hits a lot
那些要点，我认为会非常重要。是的，我也会说，我的意思是，我认为在这样做时，要有一个重点，所以，你知道，所以他们正在看关于它的 YouTube 视频，而不是真正去做。有时我不会，我从来没有制作过电子游戏，它在我的清单上，但就像，我想我有非常简单的，但从来没有真正做过，但你当你观看时会看到这一点，
of those bullet points, I think would be really important. Yeah, and I'll say too, I mean, I think in doing that, having a focus to it, so, you know, so they're watching YouTube videos on it and not actually doing it. Sometimes I don't, I've never made a video game, it's on my list, but like, I guess I have very simple ones, but never really, but you sort of see this when I watch,
而且你知道，我会在跑步机上跑步，我会看一个关于某个游戏引擎之类的 YouTube 视频。人们偶尔会发表这样的评论，哦，有很多涉猎者或刚开始的人，但实际上完成某事，你知道，这真的很难，人们并不总是这样做，所以，你知道，我们之前提到过游戏果酱（Game Jams）或者你知道，他们匆忙构建的会议，你知道，一些 AI 工具来演示公司赞助的东西
and you know, I'll be running on the treadmill and I'll watch a YouTube video about some game engine or whatever. And people make this comment occasionally like, oh, there's lots of dabbling or people who get started but actually Completing something, you know, it's really difficult people don't always do it so, you know, we've alluded to before game jams or You know sessions where they hurry up and build, you know some AI tool to demo something a company is sponsoring
我认为这些可以是很好的方式，我不会说这是唯一的方式，但这是一个很好的附加组件，你不仅学习使用新工具，而且，当 Jason 和我在播客开始前谈论这个时，我们，我正在经历，但就像使用某样东西来真正完成整个周期，不仅仅是做中间部分，有趣的部分，你知道，嘿，我把 LLM 插入了我的编辑器，我们今天谈论的，但你如何真正部署该代码？我们之前在节目中谈过。我如何集成它？我如何把它变成一个产品？我如何使用它？
I think those can be really good ways I I wouldn't say it's an only thing but it's a nice add-on where you learn to not just use a new tool, but, and when Jason and I were talking about this a bit for unrelated thing before the podcast started, that we were, I was going through, but like use something to actually do the full cycle with sort of not just do the middle part, the interesting part, the, you know, hey, I have the LLM plugged into my editor we're talking about today, but how do you actually deploy that code? We've talked about that on episodes before. How do I integrate it? How do I make it into a product? How do I use it?
因为我认为当你进入那些对话和面试时，当市场好转或者你终于让人真正和你交谈时，你会因为多次完成这个周期而显得更加自信，即使是在微型版本中。所以我建议类似那种游戏果酱或者只是想出你自己的。我犹豫是否使用“创业”这个词。我认为那有点像一条不同的道路，比如创建一个初创公司并运行它，但构建几乎像，像一个演示公司，如果那是一回事的话，就像构建一些东西，你做全套事情并了解它需要什么。思考它，学习它，不是为了赚钱的唯一目的，而是为了教学
Because I think that when you go into those conversations and interviews when either the market turns around or you finally do get you know somebody to actually talk to you, you're gonna come across much more confidently as having done the cycle a few times even if it's in miniature. And so I would say sort of those kinds of like game jams or just coming up with your own. I hesitate to use the word startup. I think that's sort of like a different path, like making a startup and running it through, but building almost like, like a demo company, if that's a thing, like building something where you do the full set of things and understand what it takes. Think about it, learn it, not for the sole purpose of making money, but for the purpose of teaching
你自己，不仅仅是我们刚才说的对 Jason 和我来说是重点的那个非常狭窄的切片。但我认为如果你想要进入的能力，自己深入研究分布式数据库真的很难。但这并不意味着你不能学习所有关于为什么分布式数据库有意义的片段，或者各种权衡看起来会是什么样子。是的，这有道理。所以，好的。你会，所以，你知道，湾区我认为是一个开始职业生涯的好地方。你知道，我想如果我开始我的职业生涯，我会搬到湾区，
yourself more than just the very narrow slice that we were kind of saying that is our focus now for Jason and I. But I think if you want the ability to get in, it's really hard to get really deep on distributed databases by yourself. But that doesn't mean you can't learn about all of the pieces of why a distributed database makes sense or what the various trade-offs would look like. Yep, that makes sense. So, okay. Would you, so, you know, the Bay Area is I think a great place to start a career. You know, I think if I was starting my career, I would move to the Bay Area,
这正是，我所做的，也是 Patrick 所做的。嗯，所以我认为这在今天仍然适用。所以问题是，你会搬到湾区之前找工作吗？我，我，也许这是一个热门的个人观点。我不会。我也不会。也许这是一个热门的个人观点，我不会。我也不会。我认为那里，如果你愿意搬家，
which is exactly what, what I did and what Patrick did. Um, so I think that's still true today. So question, would you move to the Bay Area before getting a job? I, I, maybe this is a hot take personal opinion. I would not. I would also not. maybe this is a hot take, personal opinion, I would not. I would also not. I think there, if you were willing to move,
可能有地方，即使你正在寻找那种会议和志同道合的个人的接触，一些大学城，我想，我们谈论像奥斯汀或其他地方，那些甚至是，你可以计划访问的地方，计划与这些活动同时进行，而且假设你处于较低的生活成本，这对你的钱更有用
there are probably places, even if you were looking for exposure of those kinds of meetings and fellow like-minded individuals, some college towns, I think, we talk about places like Austin or other places where those are even, places you could visit, plan to coincide with these events and sort of it's more useful for your money assuming you're sort of in a lower cost of living
比湾区已经。搬到湾区非常、非常昂贵，而且湾区的大多数人要么已经在那里，要么在那里上学，要么有工作，不再那样做了。是的，完全同意。我想，你知道，你想做什么，我不确定怎么做，但你想向招聘人员发出信号，你知道，你愿意搬迁，
than the Bay Area already. Moving to the Bay Area is very, very expensive and most of the people in the Bay Area are either already there or are going to school there or have a job and aren't really doing that as much anymore. Yeah, totally agree. I think, you know, what you want to do, and I'm not sure how to do this, but you want to signal to recruiters, you know, that you're willing to relocate,
也许只是在简历上写上“愿意搬迁”。有很多人不愿意搬迁，所以如果你在简历上写上这一点，招聘人员就不必担心你了。我认为社交媒体上有很多 Patrick 看不到的帖子，关于 SF 是行动所在，你必须搬到 SF，你知道，把那个放在一边，我想。即使你接受这个前提，嗯，我认为在没有工作的情况下走到行动所在的地方，呃，不是，不是一个好主意，坦率地说。我认为它，正如 Patrick 所说，极其昂贵的地区。
maybe just literally putting willing to relocate on your resume. There's a lot of people who are not willing to relocate on your resume. There's a lot of people who are not willing to relocate and so the recruiter doesn't have to worry about that with you if you put that on your resume. I think that there's a lot of posts on social media that Patrick doesn't see about how, SF is where the action is, you have to move to SF and you know, putting that aside, I think. Even if you accept the premise, um, I think going to where the action is without a job, uh, is not, not a good idea to be frank. I think that it's, as Patrick said, extremely expensive area.
嗯，你会遇到人，但同样，很多人可能没有在招聘。他们可能在做自己的事情。他们可能在大型公司，所以他们拥有的影响力是有限的。你一天或一个月能对那个人产生多大的影响？如果建立关系需要一年，
Um, and you will meet people, but again, a lot of those people might not be hiring. They might be doing their own thing. They might be at big companies and so they're limited in what kind of influence they have. How much influence can you have on that person in a day or a month? If it's gonna take a year to build a relationship,
你真的要花几千美元住在那里吗？嗯，这似乎不是一个明智的决定。我觉得，嗯，你知道，如果一家公司是，是，呃，我认为放，放“愿意搬迁”，真正试图专注于那些会让你面对面面试的公司。所以他们是认真的。嗯，然后最终通过公司搬迁将是做到这一点的方法。
are you really gonna spend all the thousands of dollars to live there? Um, it seems like not a wise decision. I feel like, um, you know, if a company is, is, uh, I think putting, putting willing to relocate, really trying to focus on companies that are going to have you interview in person. So they're serious. Um, and then ultimately getting relocated with a company would be the way to do that.
我同意。我认为即使一家公司说他们有远程工作的选择，即使，你知道，这对你来说可能非常有吸引力或令人向往，如果你的主要重点是找工作和开始，我确实认为无论他们说什么，仍然有偏好，它有点回到那个工作。就像可能有一个工作机会。那个工作几乎肯定，就像在任何地点都有更高的概率想要面对面，
I agree. I think even if a company says they have options for remote working and even though, you know, that may be very appealing or desirable to you, if your primary focus is to get a job and like to get started, I do think regardless of what they say, there is still preferences and it sort of comes back to that job. Like there may be a job available. That job is almost certain, like has a much higher probability of wanting to be in person in whatever location,
你知道，他们正在寻找的，有很小的外部机会，如果有一个杰出的候选人，而推动雇佣该候选人的事情是让他们远程工作，那么就像有一个选择。所以他们会把它放进去，但这并不意味着它对你来说是一个选择。我知道这很糟糕。就像有些公司，如果一家公司是远程优先的公司，你知道，完全忽略该信息。但我认为类似于 Jason 所说的，我认为如果你有强烈的重点或渴望在湾区，或者如果你愿意做极端的事情来获得极端的结果，你可以忽略我们的建议。是的，当然，做你自己的事情。我想 Jason 和我正在说的，试图在标准差内采取这个
you know, that they're looking for with a small outside chance that if there was an exceptional candidate and the thing that moved the needle to hire that candidate was letting them work remote, that there's like an option. So they'll put it in, but that doesn't mean it's an option for you. And I know that sucks. Like there are companies that if a company is a remote first company, you know, this is completely disregard that information. But I think similar to what Jason is saying, I think you can disregard our advice if you have a strong focus or desire to be in the Bay Area or if you're willing to do extreme things to get extreme results. Yeah, of course, take your own thing. I think what Jason and I are saying, trying to take this within one standard deviation of the normal
分布。做点什么，但不要做最极端、风险最大的事情。所以我们试图在这个建议中取得平衡。是的。是的。我想这有道理。嗯，是的，我确实认为，你知道，对于入门级的人，我认为远程，你知道，这里很好。
distribution. Do something, but don't of the normal distribution, like do something, but don't do the most extreme, most risky thing. So we're trying to sort of strike a balance there in this advice. Yeah. Yeah. I think that makes sense. Um, yeah, I do think that, you know, for entry level folks, I think being remote, you know, it's nice here.
你可以留下来，你知道，呃，你知道，在你住的任何地方，嗯，你知道，这里很好，你可以留下来，你知道，在你住的任何地方，你知道，除非你碰巧在你现在住的地方找到工作。但我认为只是，你知道，我们归根结底都是社会性动物，我只是不知道心理上人们是否真的以同样的方式处理远程工作者和本地工作者，并且真的真的把他们当作平等的对待。我只是认为这是我们本性的事实，所以你寻求进步，我认为如果你是入门级的，并且你寻求进步，我认为搬到公司所在的任何地方可能是一个好主意。好的，现在 Patrick，你会搬到像
You get to stay, you know, uh, you know, in, in wherever you're living, um, you know, it's nice here you get to stay, you know, in wherever you're living, you know, unless you happen to get a job where you're living now. But I think that the just, you know, we're all social animals at the end of the day and I just don't know if psychologically people really kind of handle remote workers and local workers the same way and just really are really treating them like equally. I just think that that's that's just the fact of our nature and so you're looking to get ahead I think that if you're entry-level and you're looking to get ahead I think that moving to wherever the company is is probably a good idea. Okay, now Patrick, would you move to like the middle
荒郊野外吗？我想，你知道，是的，我会。我有点，没给你回答的机会。好的，如果他们给你一份工作，但你必须搬到那里，你会搬到荒郊野外吗？我的意思是，这听起来真的，我不认为你的主要重点应该是，你知道，本身就是钱，但如果是机会和奖品。我的意思是，这听起来真的，我不认为你的主要重点应该是，你知道，本身就是钱，
of nowhere? I guess, you know, yeah, I would. I'm kind of a, didn't give you a chance to answer. Okay, would you move to the middle of nowhere if they offered you a job but you had to move there? I mean, it sounds really, I don't think your primary focus should be, you know, per se money, but if it was opportunity and for a prize. I mean, it sounds really, I don't think your primary focus should be, you know, per se money,
但如果是机会和奖品，我的意思是，我想——而且你是入门级的，你知道，你不是 Patrick，你的入门级是——是的，作为入门级，我的意思是，假设你没有，你知道，10 个录取通知，对吧？
but if it was opportunity and for a prize, I mean, I think- And your entry level, you know, you're not Patrick, your entry level is- Yeah, as entry level, I mean, and assuming you don't, you know, have 10 offers, right?
对。是的，我想，是的，有，找一份工作并获得经验，我想对大多数人来说，历史上与父母、祖父母交谈，那种东西，他们拥有的工作数量要少得多。他们居住的地方数量要少得多。
Right. Yeah, I think, yeah, having, getting a job and getting experience, I think for most folks, historically talking to parents, grandparents, that kind of stuff, the number of jobs they had was a lot lower. The number of places they lived was a lot lower.
但就个人而言，即使只是稍微灵活一点，我知道更灵活的人已经是一个优势。如果你愿意搬家，如果你愿意换工作，那里有一个平衡，但总的来说这让你，我觉得这是一种帮助。
But personally, even just being mildly flexible and I know people who were more flexible has been an advantage. If you're willing to move, if you're willing to change jobs, that there's a balance there, but in general that makes you, I feel like it's a help.
是的，是的。是的，我正在考虑我拥有的这个绝佳机会，它在英国，你知道我有孩子，所以我真的不愿意那样做，连根拔起我的整个家庭去英国。但如果我没有孩子，别人抓住了那个机会，这是一个很好的机会。所以我认为如果你刚从大学出来，那对你来说是一个选择，你的地点灵活性，我认为，是一个巨大的资产。好的，哦，继续。
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, I'm thinking about this amazing opportunity that I had that was in the UK and you know I had kids so I wasn't willing to really do that, uproot my whole family and go to the UK. But if I didn't have kids, someone else took that opportunity, which is a great one. So I think if you're fresh out of college, that is an option for you, is your location flexibility, I think, is a huge asset. All right, oh, go ahead.
我本来想说，好吧，如果你还没有调走，因为它真的很令人沮丧，我也会说时代在变，我们已经看到事情从，而且长期我本来想说，好吧，如果你还没有调走，因为它真的很令人沮丧，我也会说时代在变，我们已经看到事情从，而且长期我仍然看好，所以我猜坚持住。就像它听起来很俗气，但是的，这并非全是厄运和阴霾。就像事情现在可能很艰难，
I was gonna say, well, if you haven't tuned off, because it's really depressing, I will say also times change, and we've seen things go from, and long-term I was gonna say, well, if you haven't tuned off because it's really depressing, I will say also times change and we've seen things go from, and long-term I'm still bullish, so I guess hang in there. Like it sounds cheesy, but yeah, this is not all doom and gloom. Like things can be tough now,
但它们可以好转，只要坚持下去。哦，完全。我的意思是，我现在就给出我的预测，我们会看看我是否正确。五年后听这期节目的人可以给我发一封 ASCII 电子邮件，但我认为五年内构建 AI 工具的人会比 Web 开发人员多。所以我认为有一个巨大的需求，我们只是处于甚至
but they can turn around and just keep at it. Oh, totally. I mean, I'll give my prediction right now and we'll see if I'm right. Someone who listens to this episode five years from now can send me an ASCII email, but I think there will be more people building tools for AI than web developers within the next five years. So I think that there's a massive need and we're just on the cusp of even
认识到这种需求的风口浪尖，但我认为它是巨大的。所以我认为，你知道，事情绝对会反弹。而且实际上，我的意思是，只是即兴发挥。是的。我的意思是，你知道，现在最好的事情可能是接受南达科他州那份为薯片工厂工作的工作。我的意思是，就像字面上的薯片工厂作为他们的软件工程师，你知道，只是为了让你度过接下来的几年，
recognizing this need, but I think it's enormous. And so I think that, you know, things will absolutely bounce back. And actually, I mean, just riffing on that. Yeah. I mean, you know, maybe the best thing to do right now is to take that job in South Dakota, working for the chip factory. I mean, like literally the potato chip factory as their software engineer, you know, just to get you through the next couple of years,
给你经验。因为我确实认为事情会以巨大的方式反弹。好的。好吧，你在这里第一次听到了。好的。所以在我们有史以来最长的介绍主题之后，新闻和链接，去吧，Pat。是的，那，那很粗糙，要快一点。所以我很快。好的，所以这个是最近的新闻，但要谈论一个更广泛的主题经典新闻节目新闻搬到这里，但《马里奥赛车 64》被完全反编译了。所以这是
give you experience. Cause I do think that things will bounce back in a big way. All right. Well, you heard it here first. All right. So after our longest intro topic ever, news and links, go for it, Pat. Yeah, that was, that was rough to be a little speedy here. So I'll be quick. Alright, so this one is a recent news, but to talk about a broader topic classic news news of the show move here, but Mario Kart 64 was fully decompiled. So this is
实际上是一个有趣的兔子洞。具体来说，一些《塞尔达》游戏一直在谈论这个，现在是《马里奥赛车 64》。这是一件有趣的事情，人们试图编写编译成字节相同的 ROM 的源代码。你说，好吧，为什么？我的意思是，好吧，首先，如果你有恰好编译的源代码，它有点像版权周围的漏洞。所以你不能分发像精灵和东西这样的资产，它们受版权保护，但如果你编写自己独特的源代码，恰好编译成同样的东西，
actually an interesting rabbit hole. Specifically, some of the Zelda games this has been talking about now, Mario Kart 64. And this is an interesting thing where people attempt to write source code that compiles basically to byte identical ROM. And you say, well, why? I mean, well, for one, if you have source code that just happens to compile, it's sort of like a loophole around copyright. So you can't distribute assets like sprites and things are covered by copyright, but if you write your own unique source code that just happens to compile to the same thing,
这开启了一些有趣的开源机会。它还允许人们进入并改变行为，以及进行优化、修复错误、进行小改动。我们稍后会谈论一点，我会带回这个，但只是围绕对现有游戏做事情开启了一个环境。所以《马里奥赛车 64》，显然在这一点上是一个老游戏了，
that opens up some interesting open source opportunities. It also allows people to get in and sort of change behavior as well as like do optimization, fix bugs, make small changes. And we're gonna talk about a little later, I'll bring this back, but just opens up an environment around sort of doing things with an existing game. So Mario Kart 64, obviously a well-aged game at this point,
这开启了一些有趣的开源机会。它还允许人们进入并改变行为，以及进行优化、修复错误、做出小幅修改。我们稍后会谈到这一点，我会再提回来，但这只是围绕着对现有游戏进行操作开启了一个环境。所以《马力欧卡丁车64》，显然是一款在这一点上已经非常成熟的游戏了，
but even things like, you know, sort of running it natively on your computer rather than an emulator of the ROM is opened up by things like having the source code and doing optimizations and just a really fascinating sort of thing. So if you've never looked at it before, we've talked about sort of emulation and stuff off and on, but definitely a really kind of cool thing.
但即使是像在电脑上原生运行，而不是通过模拟器运行 ROM 这样的事情，也因为有了源代码和优化而变得可能，这确实是一件非常迷人的事情。所以如果你以前从未关注过，我们断断续续地聊过模拟器之类的话题，但这绝对是一件非常酷的事情。
And there's a whole bunch of them that have been done at this point, sort of some GameCube games. And so some N64 games now too. So it's sort of a fascinating thing that I think, even me as like a, I'll call like an enthusiast, since I just generally didn't know about, but like reading about it, it's definitely pretty cool. Yeah, I mean, this code is like very readable
目前已经有相当多这样的作品了，比如一些 GameCube 游戏，现在还有一些 N64 游戏。所以这是一件很迷人的事情，我想即使是我这样一个，我称之为爱好者的人，之前也完全不知道，但读到这些内容时，确实觉得非常酷。是的，我的意思是，这些代码非常易读，
compared to what I had imagined it was gonna be. Yeah, it's not just like whatever, what is that, IDA or whatever, where you disassemble and sort of like, that's not what like whatever, what is that IDA or whatever where you disassemble and sort of like, that's not what they mean here, even though the wording isn't super clear. It's not just, here's the assembly instructions that this maps do. Yeah, yeah, I mean, all the functions are named
比我预想的要好得多。是的，这不仅仅是像什么 IDA 之类的工具，通过反汇编来分析，那不是他们在这里的意思，尽管措辞不是很清楚。这不仅仅是把汇编指令映射出来。是的，是的，我的意思是，所有的函数都命名为
with like a semantic name and a lot of the variables are named correctly. This is really impressive. So someone did this by hand? I think it's a combination of sort of getting those very coarse garbage C, C sort of like messed up names and then slowly teasing apart the threads, right? Like, oh, this variable does name something irrelevant. Let me give a semantic name because now I know it's the velocity of the cart or whatever, right? And so I think you slowly by slowly work through unpacking the code. Wow, that's amazing.
具有语义的名称，而且很多变量也命名得很准确。这真的很令人印象深刻。所以这是有人手工完成的吗？我认为这是将那些非常粗糙、混乱的 C 语言名称，通过慢慢梳理脉络整理出来的结果，对吧？比如，“哦，这个变量名不相关，让我给它起个有意义的名字，因为现在我知道它是小车的速度之类的”，对吧？所以我认为你是通过一点一点地拆解代码来完成的。哇，那太神奇了。
Wow, what a work of art. Very cool. Okay, mine is, my first news is Q learning is not yet scalable. And so this is an article. I've had like five people send me this article. It's kind of funny, but I read it a few times. It's a good article. I mean, the gist of it is, yeah, without spending a lot of time, because I do want to get to AI tools, basically, Q learning is what powered AlphaGo
哇，真是艺术品。太酷了。好了，我的第一条新闻是“Q学习尚不可扩展”。这是一篇文章。大概有五个人发给我这篇文章。这很有趣，但我读了几遍。这是一篇好文章。我的意思是，它的要点是，是的，为了节省时间，因为我确实想谈谈 AI 工具，基本上，Q学习是驱动 AlphaGo 的核心，
and Atari players, a whole bunch of things. It works for some of these environments because there's almost no noise in the state. It's like an Atari game, it's very clear what's happening. A Go game is totally deterministic. Um, and so if you were to try to use Q learning to like drive a car or, you know, operate a robot with a camera where it's very noisy, it has all sorts of challenges, um, and, uh, um, you know, and I think this really shows that
还有 Atari 玩家，以及很多其他东西。它在某些环境中有效，因为状态中几乎没有噪声。就像 Atari 游戏一样，发生的事情非常清晰。围棋游戏是完全确定性的。嗯，所以如果你试图用 Q学习来驾驶汽车，或者操作一个带有摄像头的机器人，那里噪声很大，就会遇到各种各样的挑战，嗯，而且，嗯，你知道，我认为这确实表明
there's just so much more work that needs to happen in reinforcement learning. I mean, I'll throw my hat into the rink here. I think that the reward function engineering is not really the way to go. So just to recap, they take Go, for example. You play a game of Go, you win, you get a point at the end of the game. If you lose the game, you get a minus one point. And then the Q learning tries to take actions
强化学习领域还有很多工作要做。我的意思是，我要发表一下我的看法。我认为奖励函数工程并不是未来的方向。简单回顾一下，他们以围棋为例。你下一盘围棋，赢了，游戏结束时得一分。如果输了，得负一分。然后 Q学习试图采取行动，
that will give you that point. But that is like extremely clean, right? Like it's zero sum, it's perfectly zero sum and you don't have to do a lot of massaging to that reward to make it, uh, make it work. Um, by contrast, like Atari is more difficult where you get a score. The score is always almost always positive, right? So it's like, you always did something.
从而让你获得那一分。但这非常纯粹，对吧？它是零和博弈，完全是零和，你不需要对奖励进行太多修饰就能让它起作用。相比之下，Atari 游戏更难，因为你会得到一个分数。分数几乎总是正的，对吧？所以就像是，你总是做了点什么。
Right. Um, but it's like, I got a score of a thousand in breakout. What does that even mean? Is that a good game? Is that a bad game? Like we just, I don't know. I mean, I literally don't even know what a score of thousand is in that game. Um, and so what you have to do is construct a baseline and say like, okay, I got a score
对。嗯，但就像是，我在《打砖块》里得了 1000 分。那意味着什么？那是一场好游戏吗？还是一场坏游戏？我们只是，我不知道。我的意思是，我甚至不知道在那款游戏中 1000 分意味着什么。嗯，所以你必须做的是建立一个基准，说，“好吧，我得了 1000 分，
of a thousand that used to be really great, but my AI is better now. And so a thousand is not actually that good. And so don't do that. Like that thing that got you a score of a thousand, try not to do that next time. Do this other thing that got you a score of 10,000. Right. Um, and so you constantly have to keep moving the goal posts and, uh, there's not a good way to do that.
那曾经非常棒，但我的 AI 现在更强了。所以 1000 分其实没那么好。”所以不要那样做。那个让你得了 1000 分的操作，下次尽量别做了。做那个让你得了 10000 分的操作。对。嗯，所以你必须不断地移动目标，而且没有一个好的方法来做到这一点。
And I think that this is like a fundamental, like foundational flaw in reinforcement learning because humans don't work this way. I mean, humans have like, so humans have this in a sense where like, you know, when we first started coding, it's like, oh my God, I got a linked list to work. It's like amazing. Like you go celebrate, right? And now it's like, why did you code a linked list? Like, why didn't you just use the package? Like we kind of like moved on. But I think that the way humans go about kind of learning and advancing is they set kind of a goal
我认为这是强化学习中一个根本性的、基础性的缺陷，因为人类不是这样工作的。我的意思是，人类在某种意义上有这种感觉，比如，当我们刚开始编程时，就像，“天哪，我让链表跑通了。”这太棒了。你会去庆祝，对吧？而现在就像，“你为什么要写链表？为什么不直接用现成的包？”我们已经向前看了。但我认为人类学习和进步的方式是，他们在脑海中设定一个目标，
in their mind's eye. Like you use your really high level thinking to set a high level goal that may or may not be attainable and then you try to attain it. And so this is very different than saying like I just want more points. So I do feel like the reason it's not scalable is that we're not really kind of solving the right problem. I think that we should have like a really high level system, maybe an LLM or something like that, say, hey, try to get Mario on this pipe. And then Mario gets on the pipe and then the LLM says, okay, try to have Mario like jump over this chasm versus trying to have this reward function that captures
就像你用高层思维设定一个可能实现也可能无法实现的高层目标，然后尝试去实现它。这与“我只是想要更多分数”非常不同。所以我确实觉得它不可扩展的原因是我们没有真正解决正确的问题。我认为我们应该有一个非常高层的系统，也许是一个大语言模型之类的，说，“嘿，尝试让马里奥跳上那个水管。”然后马里奥跳上了水管，接着大语言模型说，“好吧，尝试让马里奥跳过那个深渊”，而不是试图用一个捕捉一切的奖励函数。
everything. So that's my opinion. I'm sure there's a hundred other opinions. We'll see, you know, over the next few years what happens, but it does feel like reinforcement learning could benefit from all this LLM stuff. LLMs have benefited a lot from reinforcement learning, but we haven't seen it go in the other direction as much. Oh, okay.
所以这是我的观点。我相信还有一百种其他观点。我们会在未来几年看看会发生什么，但确实感觉强化学习可以从所有这些大语言模型的东西中受益。大语言模型已经从强化学习中受益良多，但我们还没有看到它在另一个方向上有太多的进展。哦，好的。
Yeah, I have some thoughts here, but yeah, I think you're right. Let's wait and see and move on to the next one, completely unrelated. My next news article is a YouTube video actually by 3Blue1Brown. This actually came out a little bit ago about Grover's algorithm, which is sort of a generic quantum algorithm for solving like a complete class of, oh gosh, what did you say? NP-complete problems. And so if, you know, traveling salesmen, there's a bunch of things work around sort of mapping algorithms to be this NP complete and how many of them are, or most of them, all of them are, are the same fundamental thing. And Gerber's algorithm is sort of a way of, of kind of solving that.
是的，我有一些想法，但确实，我认为你是对的。让我们拭目以待，进入下一个话题，完全不相关。我的下一篇新闻文章实际上是 3Blue1Brown 的一个 YouTube 视频。这其实是前段时间发布的，关于 Grover 算法，这是一种通用的量子算法，用于解决一类完整的，哦天哪，你刚才说什么？NP 完全问题。所以，你知道，旅行商问题，有很多东西围绕着将算法映射为 NP 完全问题，以及其中有多少，或者大多数，所有这些都是同样的基本东西。而 Grover 算法就是一种解决这个问题的方法。
And, uh, this video explains something that I guess I had missed for a long time. So we covered, um, quantum computers a couple of times in the past, several times people have, you know, Hey, you guys didn't quite get it right. Yeah, they were right a couple of times in the past. Several times people have, you know, hey, you guys didn't quite get it right. Yeah, they were right. I didn't completely understand it. It's a very complex, nuanced topic. This video sort of walks it through and helped me sort of understand. I won't say I've got it now, but I definitely understand that I didn't understand before. So I guess that's step one is, you know, knowing that you don't know is half the battle. Wait, that's not quite right. Anyways, so if you've not seen this, I mean,
而且，嗯，这个视频解释了一些我猜我很久以来一直没弄明白的东西。所以我们过去几次讨论过量子计算机，好几次人们说，“嘿，你们没完全说对。”是的，他们过去几次是对的。我没完全理解它。这是一个非常复杂、微妙的话题。这个视频梳理了一遍，帮助我理解了。我不会说我现在完全懂了，但我确实明白了我以前没懂。所以我想第一步是，你知道，知道自己不知道是成功的一半。等等，那不太对。总之，如果你没看过这个，我的意思是，
pretty popular YouTubers, or most people, I think Grant is his name. Anyways, is most people will have seen this. But if you haven't, definitely watch it. I will also say there was a bit missing for me. He released a follow-up video to sort of like give sort of like a little bit more explanation of what was sort of a gap in kind of why some of the things he was saying made sense. But actually, very illuminating. Also, we've talked about before some of the problems around quantum computers and even understanding what will happen when we have quantum computers and what will or won't sort of, uh, happen. And there's a lot of interesting nuance around that in this video helps sort of explain some of that.
相当受欢迎的 YouTuber，或者大多数人，我想他叫 Grant。总之，大多数人都看过这个。但如果你没看过，一定要看。我还要说，对我来说有一点缺失。他发布了一个后续视频，算是对之前解释中一些逻辑缺口做了补充。但实际上，非常具有启发性。此外，我们之前讨论过量子计算机周围的一些问题，甚至理解当我们拥有量子计算机时会发生什么，以及什么会或不会发生。这周围有很多有趣的细微差别，这个视频有助于解释其中的一些。
Like what, what do you think this speed up will kind of be? And my, you know, there's even a poll at the very beginning and yeah, I got it wrong. Um, well, I kind of knew I was going to get it wrong. So I didn't get it wrong, but that was only because, you know, you kind of see a trap, you don't walk into it. Yeah. That kind of thing.
比如，你认为这种加速会是什么样的？我的，你知道，最开始甚至有一个投票，是的，我选错了。嗯，我其实知道我会选错。所以我没选错，那只是因为，你知道，你看到一个陷阱，你不会走进去。是的。就是那种感觉。
Anyways. And so it turns out, you know, we all think about Shor's algorithm, which is factoring of prime numbers and how that's, you know, a sort of huge speed up over, you know, any traditional method, but that's a sort of unique case. It isn't necessarily true that every computation that, for instance, is NP-complete will get that level of speed up. So it's definitely a speed up, but not
总之。结果证明，你知道，我们都想到 Shor 算法，也就是质数分解，以及它相对于任何传统方法是如何实现巨大加速的，但这是一种特殊情况。并不一定意味着每一个计算，例如 NP 完全问题，都能获得那种程度的加速。所以它绝对是一种加速，但不是
sort of the same profound as people who. It's sort of weird, because I think most people wouldn't even know about the thing of quantum computers, or even what it is other than just it's a name mapped to a concept. But for people who kind of like, oh, I know about computers. What are quantum computers? You know that next level then there's like, you know, two or three more levels of understanding past it. And so if you're in similar boat as me, which is I don't know maybe a fair decent number of people. Here's a good way to level up your understanding.
那种人们认为的深刻程度。这有点奇怪，因为我认为大多数人甚至不知道量子计算机是什么，或者除了它是一个映射到概念的名字之外，它是什么。但对于那些像，“哦，我知道计算机。什么是量子计算机？”的人来说，你知道那是下一个层次，然后还有两三个更深层次的理解。所以如果你和我处境相似，也就是我不知道，也许有相当多的人。这是一个提升你理解力的好方法。
And I thought it was well handled in treating sort of the state space of the quantums and the vectors for it, as opposed to just the hand wavy magic qubit. And so I definitely would recommend it. Hopefully folks have seen it already because I thought it was really interesting. But if you haven't and this at all, vague description of it,
而且我认为它在处理量子状态空间和向量方面处理得很好，而不是仅仅用那种挥手式的魔法量子比特。所以我绝对会推荐它。希望大家已经看过了，因为我觉得它真的很有趣。但如果你没看过，而这个模糊的描述，
I'm trying to like not recite the video because I'll screw it up. And he was very diligent to be very careful. So sorry, pardon the lack of detail. But if I've interest you by saying these keywords, quantum, computer, algorithm, NP complete, speed up, missed expectations yeah nice all right so my second one is a product actually so the company called
我尽量不去背诵视频内容，因为我会搞砸的。他非常勤奋，非常小心。所以抱歉，请原谅细节不足。但如果我通过说这些关键词引起了你的兴趣：量子、计算机、算法、NP 完全、加速、错失的期望，是的，很好，好的，那么我的第二个是一个产品，实际上是一家名为
orange pie I guess making fun riffing off raspberry pi although it doesn't work right because raspberry pie is a pie and it's also a computer but orange pie it's like they didn't quite get it like there isn't a they should have called it pumpkin pie right because there is no orange pie that you can eat. Is there a raspberry pie? I've never had raspberry pie. A raspberry pie is delicious I think. Is it a legit thing? I know a blueberry pie.
Orange Pi 的公司，我猜是在拿 Raspberry Pi 开玩笑，尽管这行不通，因为 Raspberry Pi 既是派（馅饼）也是计算机，但 Orange Pi，就像他们没完全搞懂一样，他们应该叫它 Pumpkin Pi（南瓜派），对吧？因为没有你可以吃的橙子派。有树莓派吗？我从来没吃过树莓派。树莓派我想应该很好吃。这是合法的吗？我知道有蓝莓派。
I'm pretty sure. Yeah, okay. Look it up. Look it up. But there is definitely no orange pie. That sounds disgusting. Like baked bread and then just orange rinds. I don't know. It seems gross. Okay. Orange Pi has a RISC-V single board computer. So it looks exactly like a Raspberry Pi. I'm probably going to pick one up just for fun. It has the same form factor. It has like some AI chip, which I don't know if we're too early for that. But it has ethernet ports, it has HDMI and all that good stuff, just like a Raspberry
我很确定。是的，好吧。查一下。查一下。但绝对没有橙子派。那听起来很恶心。就像烤面包然后放上橙子皮。我不知道。这看起来很恶心。好吧。Orange Pi 有一款 RISC-V 单板计算机。所以它看起来和 Raspberry Pi 一模一样。我可能会买一个来玩玩。它有相同的规格。它有一个 AI 芯片，我不知道我们现在用它是不是太早了。但它有以太网端口，有 HDMI 和所有那些好东西，就像 Raspberry
Pi, but it runs RISC 5 instead of ARM. And so in one sense that makes things a lot more difficult. I probably wouldn't want to run an emulator. I wouldn't want to use this for video games because the ARM core is so central to a lot of the video game emulators and all that. But it'd be fun as a toy to play around with and maybe it would do video transcoding well, so you could run a Plex server on it or something. But what I took away from reading this in my news is that, you know, RISC-V is here. I mean, you can buy RISC-V SBC today
Pi 一样，但它运行的是 RISC-V 而不是 ARM。所以从某种意义上说，这让事情变得困难得多。我可能不想运行模拟器。我不想用它来玩电子游戏，因为 ARM 核心对很多电子游戏模拟器来说太核心了。但作为一个玩具玩玩会很有趣，也许它能很好地进行视频转码，所以你可以在上面运行 Plex 服务器之类的。但我从阅读这篇新闻中得到的是，你知道，RISC-V 已经来了。我的意思是，你今天就可以买到 RISC-V 单板计算机，
and it will come to your house in a couple of days. That's pretty amazing. I mean, I feel like it's really here now and I hope that a lot of developers, you know, jump on this and, you know, the ecosystem just continues to evolve. Oh, this is cool. I hadn't seen this before. Yeah, I'm excited. I hope they continue to flesh this out.
而且几天内就会送到你家。这太神奇了。我的意思是，我觉得它现在真的来了，我希望很多开发者能加入进来，你知道，生态系统继续发展。哦，这很酷。我以前没见过这个。是的，我很兴奋。我希望他们继续完善它。
It also, yeah, it says it's optimized for DeepSeq R1 distillation models, but I don't know. I have a hard time exactly understanding what you would do with such an accelerator. It doesn't have a ton of RAM. So, okay, interesting. Yeah, I mean, it's optimized in a sense that like you get one token per second. So it only takes you like 10 minutes to get your answer as opposed to an hour. Okay, I'm just gonna leave this one here. Okay. That's cool though. Yeah, I'm excited. I think more competition in the space is going to be good, especially with the sort of more open source nature
它也，是的，它说它针对 DeepSeq R1 蒸馏模型进行了优化，但我不知道。我很难确切理解你会用这样的加速器做什么。它没有大量的内存。所以，好吧，有趣。是的，我的意思是，它在某种意义上是优化的，比如你每秒得到一个 token。所以你只需要 10 分钟就能得到答案，而不是一个小时。好吧，我把这个留在这里。好吧。不过那很酷。是的，我很兴奋。我认为这个领域的竞争会是好事，特别是考虑到这种更开源的性质，
and reduced licensing fees for the instructions that architecture I think is going to be pretty cool. All right. We'll get the show. All right. Mine is the Will of the Many, which is a newer series by James Islington. I think I've mentioned a previous series of his before
以及指令集架构的授权费用降低，我认为这会非常酷。好了。我们开始节目吧。好的，我的是《众生之志》（The Will of the Many），这是 James Islington 的一个新系列。我想我之前提到过他的一个系列，
on the show, but I started on this one. And I was finally back into reading. I will say I have fallen a little bit back off. So I haven't finished it yet, but I got a decent way into this book, which starts off on sort of a classic trope that everyone hears about, you know, some, some, uh, you know, young child ends up getting enrolled in a school and, you know, anyways,
在节目里，但我开始了这本。我终于又开始阅读了。我得说我又有点懈怠了。所以我还没读完，但我读了这本书的相当一部分，它从一个每个人都听说过的经典桥段开始，你知道，某个，某个，你知道，年幼的孩子最终被学校录取，你知道，总之，
but I'm told that it's, it's, it's a really good twist on the thing. And I really liked the previous books by James Islington. So, um, I was going to do actually pulled up the back cover just to read the back cover summary. Uh, and I was like, that's kind of silly. People can do that on their own rather than just listen to my amazing voice. Read it to them. They can maybe use one of those texts to audio things if they want. But, but anyways, I definitely sort of like the concept here so far.
但我被告知这是一个非常好的转折。而且我真的很喜欢 James Islington 之前的书。所以，嗯，我其实把封底拉出来读了封底摘要。嗯，我觉得那有点傻。人们可以自己做，而不是听我美妙的声音读给他们听。如果他们想的话，他们可以用那些文字转语音的东西。但，但总之，到目前为止，我确实很喜欢这里的概念。
That's interesting, which I don't know. So probably wrong, but, uh, people do what's called seeding their will. So will is like your sort of mental physical energy and you like give a portion into this hierarchy where people kind of continue to collect them up into these organizational structures. And so you sort of join into this hierarchy as part of like your political and civil life
这很有趣，我不知道。所以可能不对，但，人们做所谓的“播种意志”。所以意志就像你的一种精神和身体能量，你把一部分投入到这个等级制度中，人们继续把它们收集到这些组织结构中。所以你作为政治和公民生活的一部分加入到这个等级制度中，
and you're seeding a portion of your individual autonomy into this to become a little bit weaker yourself and sort of join society. And, and this, uh, So it's like a, it's like a mental, mental multi-level marketing. I didn't think about it that way, but yeah, at the top, someone has some knives that are so incredibly sharp. Yeah, right. That's amazing. But yeah, and obviously even just saying that, right, you can start to think about problems.
你把个人自主权的一部分播种到这里，让自己变得稍微弱一点，从而融入社会。而且，这个，所以这就像是一个精神上的，精神上的多层次传销。我没那样想过，但是的，在顶端，有人拿着非常锋利的刀。是的，对。那太神奇了。但是的，显然即使只是说出来，对吧，你也可以开始思考问题了。
And I'm really hopeful this book will explore some of the interesting problems that come from that and corruption and so on. Wow, that sounds awesome. I'm gonna have to give that a read. I wish I was creative enough to come up with these concepts, but instead I just read. My book this show is The Intelligence Trap, which I've had a couple of friends who have read this.
我真的希望这本书能探讨一些由此产生的有趣问题，以及腐败等等。哇，那听起来太棒了。我得读读看。我希望我有足够的创造力来想出这些概念，但我只是阅读。我这节目的书是《智力陷阱》（The Intelligence Trap），我有几个朋友读过这本书。
I don't remember who recommended it to me, but it was in my, I keep a list of books. Whenever someone recommends a book to me, I pop this app open and add it to the list. And this is on the list, and so I picked it up. It's interesting. I mean, the premise is, you know, there's intelligent people, they do dumb things.
我不记得是谁推荐给我的，但它在我的，我保留了一个书单。每当有人向我推荐书时，我就打开这个应用程序并把它加到列表里。这本书在列表上，所以我买了它。这很有趣。我的意思是，前提是，你知道，有聪明人，他们做蠢事。
Sometimes like, there are things that are anti-correlated with intelligence that you wouldn't expect. So like, for example, more intelligent people tend to be more gullible. Um, that might like not be obvious. Um, and it lists a bunch of things. And then, uh, yeah, the latter half of the book is, is how to not fall into these traps. So it's, so it's interesting that the audience for this book are either intelligent people or people who think they're intelligent.
有时，比如，有些事情与智力呈负相关，这是你意想不到的。所以，例如，更聪明的人往往更容易受骗。嗯，这可能不明显。嗯，它列出了一堆事情。然后，嗯，是的，书的后半部分是如何不掉进这些陷阱。所以，所以这很有趣，这本书的受众要么是聪明人，要么是自认为聪明的人。
And, and so the book kind of like affirms your, as a reader, your intelligence for, for reading the book and then, but then also tells you that you you're intelligent but you have these weaknesses because you're so intelligent so it really kind of like fans you a little bit and then and then and then talks about ways to get around it so like for example they have this thing called the off to look up, but like the RQ test and I forgot for the life of me what the R stands for but it's meant to like, oh it's meant to complement the IQ test but it's for kind of like common sense and some of these things that they feel like. Oh the readiness quotient test assesses an individual's preparedness for
所以这本书作为读者，肯定了你的智力，因为你读了这本书，但随后又告诉你，你很聪明，但你有这些弱点，因为你太聪明了，所以它真的有点像是在奉承你，然后，然后，然后谈论绕过它的方法。所以，例如，他们有这个东西叫，我得查一下，但像 RQ 测试，我忘了 R 代表什么，但它旨在，哦，它旨在补充 IQ 测试，但它是针对常识和一些他们觉得的东西。哦，准备度商数测试评估个人的准备情况，
various situations, including emergencies and challenges. So I do feel like I kind of fell into the intelligence trap trap of where I look. Exactly. So I fell into the intelligence trap trap. But, you know, given that, you given that you and I have to read, well, we're doing shows a little less frequently now, but I'd like to read a book every two weeks. So I'm not massively invested in any one book, but I don't feel like it was a waste of time. There are some interesting tidbits there,
针对各种情况，包括紧急情况和挑战。所以我确实觉得我掉进了“智力陷阱”的陷阱里，我看起来。完全正确。所以我掉进了“智力陷阱”的陷阱。但是，你知道，鉴于你和我必须阅读，嗯，我们现在做节目的频率低了一些，但我喜欢每两周读一本书。所以我并没有对任何一本书投入太多，但我不觉得这是浪费时间。那里有一些有趣的知识点，
but I do feel like it was phenomenally pretentious. You know, like the overall kind of atmosphere of the book is, you're so smart. Here's other like super geniuses are going to talk about, like Nobel Prize winners and stuff and dumb things that they've done. And here's how you could not be dumb in the same way that they're dumb, despite being so incredibly smart. That's kind of like the way I felt like the book was speaking to me, which is not a way I really like to be spoken to. So I think that there are some interesting parts.
但我确实觉得它非常自命不凡。你知道，书的整体氛围是，你太聪明了。这里有其他超级天才要谈论，比如诺贝尔奖得主之类的，以及他们做过的蠢事。这是你如何才能不以他们那种愚蠢的方式变得愚蠢，尽管你如此聪明。我觉得这本书就是这样跟我说话的，这不是我真正喜欢被对待的方式。所以我认为有一些有趣的部分。
Here's another part of the book. They talk about some guy who was like a physicist at CERN but he basically got catfished into going to Brazil to meet like a model who didn't actually exist. And then when he got to the hotel room there was a note saying, Hey, sorry, I have to do a photo shoot. But you know, and then he got an email from the model saying, Hey, I left my bag in the hotel room. I'm sorry I lost you because of the photo shoot. Let's go to Florida or someplace in America and let's meet up over there. Could you bring my clothes with me? And so this guy ends up bringing a whole suitcase full of illicit drugs to the US where he gets caught by border patrol. And he has to kind of like explain this whole story about how he got tricked.
这是书的另一部分。他们谈论一个家伙，他是 CERN 的物理学家，但他基本上被骗去巴西见一个并不存在的模特。然后当他到达酒店房间时，有一张纸条说，“嘿，抱歉，我得去拍照片。”然后他收到模特的一封电子邮件说，“嘿，我把包落在酒店房间了。很抱歉因为拍照错过了你。我们去佛罗里达或美国的某个地方见面吧。你能帮我带衣服吗？”所以这个家伙最终带了一整箱非法毒品到美国，在那里被边境巡逻队抓住了。他不得不解释他被骗的整个故事。
And so. You know, this is one example of basically they chair in my opinion they cherry picked Cases were incredibly smart people did really dumb things You know, and then they try to like also do broad things But they don't really connect them like for example, I know point did the books say more intelligent people are more likely to be catfished You know like tricked by fake identities because that's probably not true, right? more intelligent people are more likely to be catfished, like tricked by fake identities. Because that's probably not true, right?
所以。你知道，这是一个例子，基本上他们在我看来，他们挑选了聪明人做蠢事的案例。你知道，然后他们试图做广泛的事情，但他们并没有真正把它们联系起来。例如，我不知道书里是否说更聪明的人更容易被骗？你知道，被虚假身份欺骗，因为那可能不是真的，对吧？更聪明的人更容易被骗，被虚假身份欺骗。因为那可能不是真的，对吧？
That correlation is probably not there, but they found one guy, you know? That's what I was trying to figure out, is like, what is the probability that you're very intelligent, given that you were catfished, you know? Like, I don't know, it doesn't sound like it's trying to draw that conclusion.
这种相关性可能不存在，但他们找到了一个人，你知道？这就是我试图弄清楚的，就是，鉴于你被骗了，你非常聪明的概率是多少，你知道？就像，我不知道，听起来不像是在试图得出那个结论。
It feels like you can get scammed no matter what. And don't think yourself too intelligent. So what is like, if I treat it like an RPG, if I buy the book, does it increase my intelligence by 10? Like, if I'm gullible enough to buy the book, I want to be gullible enough to buy the book because it means I'm more intelligent. Like is that the, uh, so that the trade here? Here's what I think the book is doing to its readers is, you know, all of us have friends who are smart and either do or say dumb things, right? We're, we're smart and we do or say dumb things all the time. Right. And so our
感觉无论如何你都可能被骗。不要认为自己太聪明。所以，如果我把它当作 RPG，如果我买这本书，它会增加 10 点智力吗？如果我足够容易受骗去买这本书，我想变得足够容易受骗去买这本书，因为它意味着我更聪明。这是交易吗？我认为这本书对读者做的是，你知道，我们所有人都有聪明的朋友，他们要么做要么说蠢事，对吧？我们很聪明，我们一直做或说蠢事。对。所以我们的
friends see us do and say dumb things. We see our friends say dumb things all the time. Right, and so our friends see us doing say dumb things. We see our friends say dumb things. And then there's people who are like just mortal enemies with other smart people. And so the question inevitably comes up is like, if this person is so smart and so rational, how can they not have my opinions on whatever? And so this book is trying to like, I think, give people like an out, you know, instead of saying, well, there's, this is a really complex question. There's a handful of right answer, right isn't the right word, but there's like a handful of strategies.
朋友看到我们做和说蠢事。我们一直看到我们的朋友说蠢事。对，所以我们的朋友看到我们做和说蠢事。我们看到我们的朋友说蠢事。然后还有一些人，他们和其他聪明人是死敌。所以问题不可避免地出现了，如果这个人如此聪明和理性，他们怎么可能在任何事情上没有我的观点？所以这本书试图，我想，给人们一个出路，你知道，而不是说，好吧，这是一个非常复杂的问题。有几个正确的答案，正确不是正确的词，但有几个策略。
And this person picked this strategy, you pick that strategy, but neither of you are really entrapped. You just pick different strategies. Instead of going that route, it kind of creates this false dichotomy where, where it says, Oh, the people who don't agree with you, they're just trapped. They're, they're trapped by this like thing that only affects smart people and makes them dumb, but only in this way. And so it kind of allows you to escape having to face the fact that there are like just complex situations that don't really have any one right answer. I think that's kind
这个人选择了这个策略，你选择了那个策略，但你们都没有真正陷入困境。你们只是选择了不同的策略。它没有走那条路，而是创造了一种错误的二分法，它说，哦，那些不同意你的人，他们只是被困住了。他们被这种只影响聪明人并使他们变蠢的东西困住了，但只以这种方式。所以它让你逃避面对这样一个事实，即有一些复杂的局面并没有一个真正的正确答案。我想这就是
of what's going on. Maybe I'm being too cynical. No, I, I, I hear you. I think there's this thing interestingly where most people walk around without like a true good assessment of the people around them. Like I know people who I would, I don't know, I would just say are not particularly intellectual or you may call them dumb or whatever. I don't think it holds the same. Yeah. Other podcasters.
正在发生的事情。也许我太愤世嫉俗了。不，我，我听到了。我觉得有趣的是，大多数人走来走去，对周围的人没有一个真正好的评估。就像我认识一些人，我不知道，我只会说他们不是特别有知识，或者你可能称他们为笨蛋之类的。我不认为它是一样的。是的。其他播客。
Like all of them. I'm probably one of them. But like, he's probably talking about me. He's the only one I've ever seen on the show. No, I'm saying all the other shows. Oh, oh, oh, oh, okay, I got it. Anyways, yeah, I mean, I think people don't walk around with a good assessment.
就像他们所有人。我可能就是其中之一。但像，他可能在说我。他是我在节目中见过的唯一一个。不，我说的是所有其他节目。哦，哦，哦，哦，好的，我明白了。总之，是的，我的意思是，我认为人们走来走去没有一个好的评估。
I think people just, yeah, do these things. But I know, I will say, like, you got me thinking, there's just something we talk about at some point where I've noticed part of, I think people just, yeah, do these things. But I know, I will say like, you got me thinking, there's just something we talk about at some point where I've noticed part of, I think, leveling up at work is in a way that's fair and not make you a bad person, having an actual good assessment of who around you knows what's going on,
我认为人们只是，是的，做这些事情。但我知道，我会说，你让我思考，有些事情我们在某个时候谈论过，我注意到部分，我认为人们只是，是的，做这些事情。但我知道，我会说，你让我思考，有些事情我们在某个时候谈论过，我注意到部分，我认为，在工作中升级的一种方式是，以一种公平且不让你成为坏人的方式，对周围谁知道发生了什么有一个实际好的评估，
who around you is good at their job, and who around you isn't. What I realized is a lot of people go through their career without thinking about this. They just sort of like assume everyone else is like at their same level or is really, really good. Or, and I don't think that's a personally, I don't really think that's a strength.
谁擅长他们的工作，谁不擅长。我意识到很多人在职业生涯中没有考虑过这一点。他们只是假设其他人处于和他们相同的水平，或者真的，真的很好。或者，我不认为这是一个，个人而言，我不认为这是一个优势。
I think like it's, you can decide whether or not to take action on that, but like understanding and being attentive on GitHub pull requests or whatever you want to look at as your sort of... But understanding who really knows what's going on, who's really a mover and who's... It's not playing politics, it's a way for you. And I think the same is true in your day-to to day, like figuring out when you go into a business and like who are the people who actually understand what's going on and is the person you're dealing with not understanding. And it's better to just roll the dice and ask for someone else because I go in often to the bank and I need something mildly complicated. At some point,
我认为，你可以决定是否对此采取行动，但理解并关注 GitHub 拉取请求或任何你想看的东西作为你的某种……但理解谁真正知道发生了什么，谁是真正的推动者，谁是……这不是玩弄政治，这是一种方式。我认为在你的日常生活中也是如此，比如当你进入一家企业时，谁是真正了解情况的人，你正在打交道的人是否不了解。最好掷骰子问问别人，因为我经常去银行，我需要一些稍微复杂的事情。在某个时候，
you just got realized like, Whoa, the person I'm talking to isn't understanding me. I just need to ask for someone else. Like I need to just, and it's not a being mean thing. It's just, uh, there's a communication gap here. We just need to resolve it. Wow. Yeah. You're blowing my mind right now. I mean, I have to admit, I, I've never done this. I mean, I've never, maybe I'm just too inside my own head or something, but at work I generally ignore. I mean, other than when I'm doing performance reviews and all of that, but like, let's talk, let's say like my peers, for example,
你只是意识到，哇，我正在交谈的人不理解我。我只需要问问别人。就像我只需要，这不是刻薄。这只是，这里有一个沟通差距。我们只需要解决它。哇。是的。你现在让我大开眼界。我的意思是，我必须承认，我，我从来没做过这个。我的意思是，我从来没，也许我只是太沉浸在自己的脑子里了，但在工作中我通常忽略。我的意思是，除了我做绩效评估的时候，但让我们谈谈，比如我的同行，例如，
until it's time to do a performance review, I kind of just assume that everyone around me is doing whatever they're doing, but it's a good point. I mean, yeah, I really- yeah, really like super improbable. Yeah. Yeah. You're blowing my mind. I'll really, I'm gonna have to take some time and really think about that.
直到做绩效评估的时候，我只是假设我周围的每个人都在做他们正在做的任何事情，但这确实是一个好点。我的意思是，是的，我真的——是的，真的超级不可思议。是的。是的。你让我大开眼界。我真的，我得花点时间好好想想。
Sorry. Wow. Yeah. Oh, I do feel like, um, sometimes if a project isn't going very well, uh, and I just feel like there's not a future in it, it's easier to just kind of put it on the back burner. Yeah. Versus like try to save everything. Like some things aren't worth saving.
抱歉。哇。是的。哦，我确实觉得，嗯，有时如果一个项目进展得不太顺利，嗯，我觉得它没有未来，把它放在次要位置更容易。是的。而不是试图拯救一切。有些事情不值得拯救。
Ooh, okay. That cuts deep. But programming throwdown is worth saving, which is why you should subscribe to us on Patreon. We don't run ads. You know, every time I start an episode, Zencaster is like, hey, you have all these listeners. Want to insert dynamic ads? You could be making this much money. And I click the no button because we did the ads thing for a while. I didn't like
哦，好吧。这很深刻。但 Programming Throwdown 是值得拯救的，这就是为什么你应该在 Patreon 上订阅我们。我们不投放广告。你知道，每次我开始一集，Zencaster 就像，嘿，你有这么多听众。想插入动态广告吗？你可以赚这么多钱。我点击了“不”按钮，因为我们做过一段时间的广告。我不喜欢
it. I just didn't like the way it made me feel and And so, you know, we really the show really relies on you folks We don't make any money from the show. Whatever is left over we give it to various kinds of charities or we do giveaways or stuff like that, so it's really just a Contribution to our community here and we thank you for that Thank you everyone. All right well try to speed up the train here. Tool of the show, mine is a game, not surprising, just released. Pokemon Odyssey. Now before you go look for this on the Switch 2, this is a ROM hack of a Game Boy Advance and so okay this is my segue to talk about ROM
它。我只是不喜欢它让我感觉到的方式，所以，你知道，我们真的，节目真的依赖于你们。我们不从节目中赚钱。剩下的任何东西，我们都捐给各种慈善机构，或者做赠品之类的，所以这真的只是对我们社区的贡献，我们感谢你们。谢谢大家。好了，我们试着加快进度。节目工具，我的是一个游戏，不奇怪，刚发布。Pokemon Odyssey。现在在你去 Switch 2 上找这个之前，这是一个 Game Boy Advance 的 ROM 补丁，所以好吧，这是我谈论 ROM
hacks. I got into this recently. I played a ROM hack called Pokemon Unbound, which is a quality of life improvement and a new story on an existing Game Boy Advance Pokemon game. I, we were talking about, I talked about Pokemon, I think last time, and about the random number generator. And anyways, not gonna rehash that. There's some people really into it. I think you mentioned, is it Wolfie NGC or something on YouTube who does
补丁的过渡。我最近接触了这个。我玩了一个叫 Pokemon Unbound 的 ROM 补丁，这是一个生活质量改进，也是现有 Game Boy Advance 宝可梦游戏的新故事。我，我们正在谈论，我谈到了宝可梦，我想上次，关于随机数生成器。总之，不会重提那个。有些人真的很喜欢它。我想你提到了，是 YouTube 上的 Wolfie NGC 之类的吗，他做
like competitive Pokemon play? Oh yeah. So I got into that, like, not good. I still haven't played it yet, but I do watch it occasionally. Very fascinating. I realized I just don't know anything about quantum mechanics or Pokemon. Anyways, just going to keep moving on. Anyways, just gonna keep moving on. Pokemon Odyssey came out, super fascinating,
像竞技宝可梦游戏？哦，是的。所以我接触了那个，像，不太好。我还没玩过，但我偶尔会看。非常迷人。我意识到我对量子力学或宝可梦一无所知。总之，继续前进。总之，继续前进。Pokemon Odyssey 发布了，超级迷人，
retelling of the story. Most of the battles are duels, which is the tie-in to competitive Pokemon is often played as two Pokemon versus two Pokemon because you end up with a much more complex dynamic rather than just the normal sort of non-transitive rock, paper, scissors of a 1v1 battle. And so you get two Pokemon on both sides, more interesting decisions to strategies.
故事的重述。大多数战斗是决斗，这是与竞技宝可梦的联系，通常作为 2 对 2 宝可梦进行，因为你最终会得到一个更复杂的动态，而不是 1 对 1 战斗中那种正常的非传递性石头剪刀布。所以双方都有两个宝可梦，对策略有更有趣的决定。
So this game uses a 2v2 format for most of the battles. It's a more dungeon crawler sort of oriented game than the, you know, go to the gyms and fight the gym leaders. Uh, I'm really looking forward to playing this. It has been an early release up till now, but they sort of declared it as complete. And we talked about decompilation earlier, but I didn't know until mildly recently about this sort of whole thing about ROM hacks.
所以这个游戏在大多数战斗中使用 2 对 2 格式。它比去道馆和挑战道馆馆主更像是一个地牢爬行游戏。我真的很期待玩这个。到目前为止它一直处于早期发布阶段，但他们算是宣布它完成了。我们之前谈到了反编译，但我直到最近才知道关于 ROM 补丁的整个事情。
And now I've learned there's a bunch of ones for Mega Man. There's some here now for Pokemon and other games where people go in and either like add future generations of Pokemon to old games or make changes that take away frustration or there's a whole video game thing around speed running or live streaming playing these games. And so sometimes they make changes to make it harder. Like the base Pokemon game isn't particularly hard.
现在我知道有很多针对 Mega Man 的补丁。现在这里有一些针对宝可梦和其他游戏的，人们进去要么添加未来几代的宝可梦到旧游戏中，要么做出消除挫败感的改变，或者围绕速通或直播玩这些游戏有一个完整的电子游戏事物。所以有时他们会做出改变让它变得更难。比如基础宝可梦游戏并不是特别难。
So they'll do things to make it more challenging, allow the trainers to have better AI or better items or level their Pokemon to match yours. So you can't just grind away in the bushes outside and then come in and fight. They'll always sort of have the same level as you, which means you have to rely more on strategy than on just overpowering.
所以他们会做一些事情让它更具挑战性，允许训练师拥有更好的 AI 或更好的道具，或者让他们的宝可梦等级与你匹配。所以你不能只是在外面草丛里磨练，然后进来战斗。他们总是会和你保持相同的等级，这意味着你必须更多地依赖策略而不是仅仅压制。
So a bunch of things related to that, all falling under this category of ROM hacks. And the way it works is you need to have the original ROM? Just leave that and then you get basically like a diff file that you apply on to that which makes you know all of these changes But it's super interesting because it still needs to fit within the sort of parameters specs engine abilities of The original games in the original system. So super fascinating community I just wasn't aware of. And this thing looks super cool. Watch some videos on it.
所以很多相关的事情，都属于 ROM 补丁这一类。它的工作方式是你需要有原始 ROM？就留在那儿，然后你基本上得到一个 diff 文件，你把它应用到上面，这使得你知道所有这些改变。但这超级有趣，因为它仍然需要适应原始游戏和原始系统中的参数、规格、引擎、能力。所以超级迷人的社区，我只是不知道。而且这个东西看起来超级酷。看了一些关于它的视频。
Definitely looking forward to trying this one out. Very cool. Yeah, I beat the Final Fantasy Tactics 1.3, which is the name of a ROM hack for Final Fantasy Tactics. It made the game way, way, way harder. Oh no, I'm out. There's also a ROM hack for Mega Man that makes it beatable by mortals. But yeah, very cool. Yeah, ROM hacks are awesome. I'll have to check this one out. My tool to show is
绝对期待尝试这个。非常酷。是的，我通关了 Final Fantasy Tactics 1.3，这是 Final Fantasy Tactics 的一个 ROM 补丁的名字。它让游戏变得非常非常非常难。哦不，我退出了。还有一个针对 Mega Man 的 ROM 补丁，让凡人也能通关。但是的，非常酷。是的，ROM 补丁太棒了。我得看看这个。我的节目工具是
also a game. You know, we didn't want to have actual tools when the show is about tools. So my tool is actually a category of games. If you have a Netflix subscription, you can play all the games that are in that link for free. And they're all full games. In fact, they purposely don't have microtransactions
也是一个游戏。你知道，当节目是关于工具时，我们不想有真正的工具。所以我的工具实际上是一类游戏。如果你有 Netflix 订阅，你可以免费玩那个链接里的所有游戏。而且它们都是完整的游戏。事实上，它们特意没有微交易。
because Netflix doesn't want to deal with what if you put $30 of microtransactions in a game and then cancel your Netflix membership. So Netflix doesn't want to deal with that problem. So the games have zero microtransactions, zero ads, you're all totally free. The catch is, you know, every day it checks to make sure you still have a Netflix subscription. And if you don't, then it won't let you into the app. And because of that, there's some challenges around airplane mode and stuff. So I think maybe it's more than every day.
因为Netflix不想处理这种问题：如果你在游戏里充值了30美元的微交易，然后又取消了Netflix会员，该怎么办？所以Netflix不想处理这个麻烦。因此，这些游戏完全没有微交易，没有广告，完全免费。代价是，你知道，它每天都会检查以确保你仍然拥有Netflix订阅。如果你没有，它就不会让你进入应用。正因如此，在飞行模式等方面存在一些挑战。所以我认为可能检查频率不止每天一次。
Maybe it's every month or so. So you'd have to like open the app right as you're boarding the airplane, make sure that it knows you have a Netflix subscription, that you're good to go. But there's a bunch of amazing games. I was playing with my younger son, Monument Valley. The whole series, the trilogy is there for free if you have a Netflix subscription, so check that out. There's equivalent link to all the iOS apps,
也许是一个月左右检查一次。所以你得在登机时打开应用，确保它知道你有Netflix订阅，一切正常。但那里有很多很棒的游戏。我之前和我小儿子一起玩《纪念碑谷》。如果你有Netflix订阅，整个系列，也就是三部曲都是免费的，所以去看看吧。那里有对应所有iOS应用的链接，
but I linked to all the Android ones. I'm sure people can find it. Yep. All right. Time for our topic. AI assisted coding. Well, we asked the AI. No, I'm just kidding.
但我只放了所有安卓应用的链接。我相信大家能找到的。好的。现在进入我们的主题：AI辅助编程。嗯，我们问了AI。不，我开玩笑的。
This is an AI. We've been duping you the whole time. Okay. So AI assisted coding. Patrick, do you use AI assisted coding right now? I have recently gotten on this train, so I have feelings. Okay, I've been using it for about maybe a year or so, but I'm using it a lot more now than I was before, so it's been kind of ramping up.
这是一个AI。我们一直都在骗你。好吧。那么，AI辅助编程。帕特里克，你现在使用AI辅助编程吗？我最近刚开始用，所以我有一些感受。好的，我已经用了大约一年左右了，但我现在用的比以前多得多，所以它一直在不断增加。
So I'll jump into why, why to do this. Right off the bat, I mean, if you've been listening to this episode since the beginning, you know, we talked about this, it looks good for hiring managers to know that like you're on the latest tech. And I mean, that's a little bit cynical, a little bit shallow, but it's still important, especially, you know, given all the stuff we talked about. Moving on from that, the practical reasons are, it speeds up development. I do feel like I am coding faster when I'm using these tools. I felt that way even going back to autocomplete and Visual Studio 4 or whatever, when we were in college or even high school, and you could just press tab sometimes and it would skip, you know, complete a word for you. So, so this is just that but better. And so that makes you faster.
那么我来谈谈为什么要这样做。首先，如果你从一开始就一直在听这一集，你就知道我们讨论过这个问题，对于招聘经理来说，知道你掌握了最新技术看起来不错。我是说，这有点愤世嫉俗，有点肤浅，但它仍然很重要，特别是考虑到我们讨论过的所有事情。抛开这些，实际的原因是它加快了开发速度。我确实觉得在使用这些工具时我写代码更快了。即使回到大学或高中时使用Visual Studio 4之类的自动补全功能，有时你只需按一下Tab键，它就能为你补全一个单词，我当时就有这种感觉。所以，这只是那个功能的升级版。这确实让你更快了。
Another thing that I've noticed, which I didn't expect, is it catches errors. So for example, I had a situation where, you know, I wasn't like the scope wasn't, so in Python you can't actually scope variables. Like in C, you know, or C++, you could put brackets, right? And then say int i, and as soon as you close the bracket, that int i is like gone, right? as soon as you close the bracket that int I is like gone right in Python you can't do that so I had a variable that was kind of out of scope but I was I was copy pasting like a block of code and so
我注意到的另一件事，是我没预料到的，就是它能捕捉错误。例如，我遇到过一种情况，你知道，我的变量作用域不对。在Python中，你实际上无法限制变量的作用域。就像在C或C++中，你可以用花括号，对吧？然后定义一个int i，一旦你关闭花括号，那个int i就消失了，对吧？在Python中你做不到这一点，所以我有一个变量有点超出作用域，但我当时在复制粘贴一段代码，所以
when I pasted it I didn't paste I didn't update that variable correctly. And so I was using, basically a variable had the wrong name. And the tool actually said, hey, you should change this name to this. And I was like, oh yeah, you're totally right. I need to do that. So that's an example where it's not even a speed thing. I would have just missed that, ran it, got some error and had to figure it out.
当我粘贴它时，我没有正确更新那个变量。所以我当时在用一个名字错误的变量。而这个工具竟然说，嘿，你应该把这个名字改成那个。我当时就想，哦，对，你说得完全对。我需要那样做。所以这是一个例子，它甚至不仅仅是速度问题。我本来会直接忽略它，运行后得到一些错误，然后不得不去排查。
And then I'll put a third thing here in the practical section, which is, writing code that is just tedious, that just doesn't feel good to write. Maybe like scaffolding for unit tests or things like that, that just kind of like drains a bit of your energy. So those I think are the three big things. Are there any other things you think of
然后我在实用部分加上第三点，那就是编写那些枯燥乏味、写起来感觉不好的代码。比如单元测试的脚手架之类的东西，它们会消耗你的一些精力。所以我认为这是三大要点。你还能想到其他使用这些工具的理由吗？
for why to use the tools? No, but I wanted to point out something that I guess I'll make more explicit that I think you did a little bit implicit, which is when we say this topic for, I'll say sort of no code people, there's the, you know, I go to Gemini and ask in the canvas for a web app that
没有，但我指出的这一点，我想我会说得更明确一点，我觉得你刚才说得有点含蓄，那就是当我们谈论这个话题时，对于所谓的“无代码”人群，有那种，你知道，我去Gemini的画布里要求一个网页应用，
does what is the one that was do and a rotating octagon with particles in it. I see. Oh yeah. Right. Yep. Yeah. And ask it to generate code. Right.
那个应用是做什么的来着？哦，一个带有粒子的旋转八边形。我明白了。哦，对。没错。是的。然后让它生成代码。对。
And these are people who aren't fundamentally coders and I, I, I have, I don't think we're talking about that. Um, but there's a scale from there. And then on the other end of the scale, I'll arbitrarily, didn't go too deeply, put the thing that I think we're going to talk about in a second, which is sort of like the tab completion. And so for people in the space that we're talking about, to me, it's, that's a whole gradient from, I give a English text and I get code back, you know, and then on the other end, like I'm already writing code and I
这些人从根本上来说不是程序员，我，我，我不认为我们在讨论这个。但是，这之间有一个梯度。在梯度的另一端，我随意地，没太深入，放上了我认为我们马上要讨论的东西，也就是所谓的Tab键补全。所以对于我们讨论的这个领域的人来说，对我而言，这是一个完整的梯度，从我输入英文文本然后得到代码，你知道，到另一端，我已经是在写代码了，而我
just need you to do like a better auto complete or a better, you know, fill in. And I will say that, you know, internally, when we started doing stuff, people were very, very pessimistic, you know, tried stuff like a year ago, like you're saying it was no good. We didn't, you know, do it. But now even just really subtly, if we think about it in terms of speed of writing code, the tab completion was shocking. I turned it back on for the first time in a long time. I used Sea Lion, IntelliJ had did an update and they were saying, oh, you know, we added some better AI assisted, you know, tab completion local, not cloud. We're going to talk about that in a minute. And even just turning that on was like a game changer. Like instead of just tab completing the name of the class I was doing, it would know like,
只需要你做更好的自动补全或更好的填充。我得说，在内部，当我们开始做这些事情时，人们非常非常悲观，你知道，一年前尝试过，就像你说的，效果不好。我们没有，你知道，继续做。但现在，即使只是非常微妙地，如果我们从编写代码的速度来考虑，Tab键补全令人震惊。我很久以来第一次重新开启了它。我用的是CLion，IntelliJ做了一次更新，他们说，哦，你知道，我们添加了一些更好的AI辅助Tab键补全，是本地的，不是云端的。我们一会儿会讨论这个。即使只是开启它也像是一个游戏规则的改变者。就像它不仅仅是补全我正在写的类名，它还会知道，
oh, I want to do a range evaluation of this array. And so it would like go ahead and it knew the objects in the array. It knew like what to do. It opened the print, the brace for me and put the closing brace. Like it basically completed the block and it was probably like 80% correct. But because it's typing so much, it was still worth it even to just fix the small issues because I knew what I was doing. And so for me, it's thinking about that scale.
哦，我想对这个数组进行范围评估。所以它会直接去做，它知道数组里的对象。它知道该做什么。它为我打开了括号，放上了右括号。它基本上补全了整个代码块，而且准确率大概有80%。但因为它节省了大量的打字时间，即使只是修复那些小问题也是值得的，因为我知道我在做什么。所以对我来说，是在思考那个梯度。
Like what can you get today? Is it a 10X, you know, improvement? Yeah, probably not, but it's certainly not a zero or a sort of one X multiplier, you know, a zero improvement. It's somewhere in that scale. And for you it's finding where's the right spot and what task maybe is at a different level. And so I think just calling out that conversation, we talk about it for
今天你能得到什么？是10倍的提升吗？是的，可能不是，但它肯定不是零，也不是1倍的乘数，也就是零提升。它在那个梯度之间的某个位置。对你来说，就是找到正确的切入点，以及哪些任务可能处于不同的水平。所以我认为仅仅提出这个对话，我们讨论的是
programmers, people already in the field, already doing the work. How do you get faster?, how do you get faster? Not how do you get the fastest? I'm just saying, can you find a way to go a little faster than you do today? Yeah, I mean, oh man, I'm so glad you brought this up. This should be a whole section, but basically, I wanna take a moment to throw shade on non-programmers
程序员，已经在该领域工作、已经在做这项工作的人。你如何变得更快？不是如何变得最快？我只是说，你能找到一种方法比今天做得更快一点吗？是的，天哪，我很高兴你提到了这一点。这应该是一个完整的章节，但基本上，我想花点时间吐槽一下非程序员
like using this to code. This is a terrible idea, right? I mean, I think that, and it pains me to say this because I remember, and you probably remember this too, or maybe you had less of this because you actually have this depth, but like, I don't have depth
用这个来写代码。这是一个糟糕的主意，对吧？我是说，我认为，说这话让我很痛苦，因为我记得，你可能也记得，或者也许你经历得少一些，因为你确实有这种深度，但就像，我没有深度
when it comes to going down the stack, right? Like I've never written C, I've looked at it a little bit. I've definitely never done like my own compiler or anything like that. Like if anything like I've gone up the stack or I do more abstract mathy stuff, right? And so, you know, I would see people say like, oh, well, if you don't know what the compiler is doing,
在深入底层方面，对吧？比如我从没写过C语言，我稍微看过一点。我绝对从没做过像我自己的编译器之类的东西。如果说有什么的话，我是在往上层走，或者我做更多抽象的数学类工作，对吧？所以，你知道，我会看到人们说，哦，好吧，如果你不知道编译器在做什么，
then you know, you'll be screwed,'ll be screwed if your program has an issue. If you don't know how to use GDB, then eventually Python will have some really low level issue and you won't know how to fix it. That's basically turned out to not really be true, honestly. Now, being the person saying, if you don't know how to code, you know, you're like just talking to chat GPT to build your app is not going to work. Like, I feel like a hypocrite, but I really, I really do believe it in this case. I think that that this idea that like English will be the next programming language. Again like maybe true a very long time from now. Not really practically useful to think that way. I really do think that you should learn how to code and then use these tools versus the other way around. I think the tools will probably you know
那么你知道，如果你的程序出了问题，你就完蛋了。如果你不知道如何使用GDB，那么最终Python会出现一些非常底层的错误，你将不知道如何修复它。老实说，这基本上证明并不是真的。现在，作为一个说“如果你不知道如何编程，你知道，你只是和ChatGPT对话来构建你的应用是行不通的”的人，我觉得自己像个伪君子，但我确实，我确实相信这一点。我认为这种“英语将成为下一门编程语言”的想法，再次强调，也许在很久很久以后可能是真的。但从实际角度考虑并没有什么用。我确实认为你应该先学习如何编程，然后再使用这些工具，而不是反过来。我认为这些工具可能会，你知道，
teach you maybe patterns that are odd. You'd be better off building your own style. So that's that. Yeah. And the rest of this is all geared towards programmers who already know how to code. But yeah, so I would explicitly not put in the why category because you don't know how to code. That is not a good reason to use these tools. In my opinion. Yeah. So I had the, well, I guess we can start there maybe and then go down just to kind of make a, a, a structured way to get through it.
教你一些奇怪的模式。你最好建立自己的风格。所以就是这样。是的，剩下的内容都是针对已经会写代码的程序员的。但是的，所以我明确不会把它归入“为什么要使用”的类别，因为你根本不会写代码。在我看来，这不是使用这些工具的好理由。是的。所以我有了，好吧，我想我们可以从那里开始，然后往下走，以便以一种结构化的方式完成它。
So if we start at the, go to your favorite chat agent and ask it to just generate code with a simple, you know, open AI, chat, GPT, Gemini level query, you know, I want an app that is Flappy Bird. You know, maybe that one's actually in the training data. So maybe it actually does reasonable. But if you say, you know, I want high level thing, you know, I think that's the call it the sort of chat interface. And I think to Jason's point, I'm skeptical that will, you know, kind of ever work.
所以如果我们从这里开始，去你最喜欢的聊天代理，让它用一个简单的，你知道，OpenAI、ChatGPT、Gemini级别的查询来生成代码，你知道，我想要一个《Flappy Bird》应用。你知道，也许那个已经在训练数据里了。所以也许它确实做得还可以。但如果你说，你知道，我想要高层的东西，你知道，我认为这就是所谓的聊天界面。而且对于杰森的观点，我怀疑这是否，你知道，会奏效。
And I right now for sure, I think it doesn't work that well. In my opinion, I'll just sort of make it up, is if you take it one level down from there, you get to sort of, I guess people are calling that like the agentic sort of interaction. And the way that seems to work, or at least the way I've been using that. And then, you know, maybe you can kind of take it from there is that for the Agenda one, you're sort of working together to maybe say like, let's define an outline, like a plan of attack, a software description document,
而且我现在肯定认为它效果不佳。在我看来，我只是随口说说，如果你把它降低一个层次，你会得到所谓的，我想人们称之为代理式交互。而这似乎有效的方式，或者至少是我使用它的方式。然后，你知道，也许你可以从那里接手，那就是对于代理式交互，你是在一起工作，也许是说，让我们定义一个大纲，一个攻击计划，一个软件描述文档，
or, you know, a list of things to sort of say, we're gonna do step A, then step Bs, then step C. To your point, you're not, you are writing English, but you're writing a requirements document. And then you're sort of going back and asking, let's do step one. Let's test it. Let's do step two. Let's say, I have still not had personally good success with this.
或者，你知道，一个清单，来说明我们将执行步骤A，然后步骤B，然后步骤C。正如你所说，你不是，你是在写英语，但你是在写需求文档。然后你再回去要求，让我们做第一步。让我们测试它。让我们做第二步。我说，我个人在这方面还没有取得很好的成功。
It is definitely better than the, you know, just enter a chat. Um, but I, there are tools developing around it. I see Promise here, but today I don't get a lot of benefit from trying to do things this way. Yeah, another reason why... So, you know, okay, I think that, you know, you should know how to code. But, for example, I don't have a lot of experience with go the program language go and I was editing a go file and I needed to do something pretty basic and I can't remember exactly what it was. Let's just say I needed to append to an array very basic and So I just selected a block of code and I said, hey, after this code, can you append this
它绝对比，你知道，仅仅输入一个聊天要好。但是，有工具在围绕它发展。我在这里看到了希望，但今天我从尝试用这种方式做事中并没有得到太多好处。是的，另一个原因……所以，你知道，好吧，我认为，你知道，你应该知道如何编程。但是，例如，我对Go编程语言没有太多经验，我当时在编辑一个Go文件，我需要做一些非常基本的事情，我不记得具体是什么了。我们就说我需要向数组追加元素，非常基本。所以我只是选择了一段代码，我说，嘿，在这段代码之后，你能追加这个
item to this array? Which like if I knew Go, it would take me like a second. And it said it took me a minute, but I'm kind of learning the language as I go. So I think for like specific things like that, it can work. But I think, yeah, it's very different from like build me a website kind of query. For the example you have I'll you know I think it is helpful for people who aren't doing it if you're already doing you maybe already know but like the example you're giving is actually really useful because it's really hard to find examples of what works so like you said
项目到这个数组吗？如果我懂Go，这对我来说只需要一秒钟。它说它花了我一分钟，但我是在边学边做。所以我认为对于像这样的具体事情，它是可以工作的。但我认为，是的，这和“帮我建一个网站”之类的查询非常不同。对于你举的例子，我会，你知道，我认为这对那些不做这件事的人是有帮助的，如果你已经在做了，你可能已经知道了，但你给出的例子实际上非常有用，因为很难找到什么有效的工作示例，所以就像你说的
taking code highlighting it and saying hey, I want to add something new works. I'll say the example I did that is probably among the most sophisticated that surprised me that it straight up just worked the first time and was very effective is we had some sort of test code that I needed a topological traversal through something. And so I was just doing a depth first search. But then I wanted to run it on a data set
获取代码，高亮显示它，然后说嘿，我想添加一些新东西是有效的。我会说我做的那个例子可能属于最复杂的之一，让我惊讶的是它第一次就直接成功了，而且非常有效。我们有一些测试代码，我需要对某物进行拓扑遍历。所以我只是在做深度优先搜索。但后来我想在一个数据集上运行它
that was a lot bigger. And so the depth first search was not working. It wasn't efficient enough. And I needed Dykstra. You write Dykstra all the time. I know how to write Dykstra. I know what it's supposed to look like. It'll take me, what, 15, 20 minutes, you know,
那个数据集大得多。所以深度优先搜索行不通。它的效率不够高。我需要Dijkstra算法。你经常写Dijkstra。我知道怎么写Dijkstra。我知道它应该是什么样子。这会花我，什么，15、20分钟，你知道，
to write it for my data set, to switch it over, test out, probably, you know, C++ has some weird thing around priority queues I can never remember, so I'll have to go look up. It isn't gonna be instantaneous, but it isn't gonna be a whole day either. I highlighted my, if I had asked it, I don't think it would have done well,
为我的数据集写它，切换过去，测试，可能，你知道，C++在优先队列周围有一些奇怪的东西，我永远记不住，所以我得去查。它不会是瞬间完成的，但也不会花上一整天。我高亮了我的，如果我问它，我不认为它会做得很好，
but I highlighted the depth first one, which is very fast to write, and it was able to see the API I wanted, the structures, the calling, all of the right moving pieces were there just like in your example. And it got the correct priority queue, the custom sorting function for my structure, all the calls were correct, no hallucination. It literally worked the first time.
但我高亮了深度优先那个，写起来非常快，它能够看到我想要的API、结构、调用，所有正确的移动部件都在那里，就像你的例子一样。它得到了正确的优先队列，为我的结构定制了排序函数，所有的调用都是正确的，没有幻觉。它确实第一次就成功了。
It was exactly what I needed and whatever, it took 60 seconds for it to code it up. And, and then I could skim it and tell that it was, you know, generally right. And then had an easy way to test it because I already had the test harness done. And I would say that's the one that blew me away as like sort of the most sophisticated personal experience I had sort of just asking for something and getting it right. And it falls in line with what you're saying. You're highlighting something that has most of the context you want in a compact description, and you're asking for a variation on it.
这正是我所需要的，不管怎样，它只用了60秒就写好了。然后我可以浏览一下，看出它是，你知道，大致正确的。而且我有一个简单的方法来测试它，因为我已经做好了测试工具。我会说那是让我大吃一惊的一个，作为我个人经历中最复杂的一次，只是要求某事并得到了正确的结果。它符合你所说的。你高亮显示了一些在紧凑描述中包含你想要的大部分上下文的内容，并且你正在要求它的一个变体。
Yeah, another thing I've done in that vein that works really well is highlighting a block of code and saying, I want this to be its own function. It does really good, because that's actually hard for a person, because you have to go and remember the types, like assuming you're strongly typing things or using type hints, you have to go and remember the types of all these. You have to first know what local variables is this block of code using and not using,
是的，我在那个方向上做的另一件事效果非常好，就是高亮显示一段代码并说，我希望这成为它自己的函数。它做得非常好，因为这对人来说实际上很难，因为你必须去记住类型，假设你正在强类型化事物或使用类型提示，你必须去记住所有这些的类型。你必须首先知道这段代码正在使用和不使用哪些局部变量，
create the function, add those variables. Usually the way I would do it is I create a function with no arguments, paste my code in and then see where the red underscores are and say, okay, let me start adding these. Yeah. And so it was like, let's just let the AI do. So the AI is awesome at that. And okay, as far as like, you know, bigger things, I have asked AI to like, you know,
创建函数，添加这些变量。通常我的做法是创建一个没有参数的函数，粘贴我的代码，然后看看哪里有红色下划线，说，好吧，让我开始添加这些。是的。所以就像，让我们让AI来做。所以AI在这方面太棒了。好吧，至于像，你知道，更大的事情，我要求AI像，你知道，
write a unit test from scratch and it seems to do a decent job. I would say the actual test was not very good. It's like the Sentinel values they chose, and they didn't test all the edge cases, but they got kind of the scaffold up, and I was able to edit it after that. So I will say, I think, and then this is obviously limited to now, and then maybe you know, this is, you know, obviously limited to now.
从零开始写一个单元测试，它似乎做得还不错。我会说实际的测试不是很好。就像他们选择的哨兵值，他们没有测试所有的边缘情况，但他们搭建了脚手架，我可以在那之后编辑它。所以我得说，我认为，这显然仅限于现在，然后也许你知道，这，你知道，显然仅限于现在。
And then maybe we can, you know, talk more about some of the tools, which I think will evolve as the sort of underlying LLMs evolve and stuff. But the thing that bump up against it may be obvious to people, but wasn't intuitive to me, I guess, like I kind of know it at a conceptual level, but not how it works in practice. But the examples you're saying, the examples I'm saying all share that more or less you can take a whole file or a big portion of a file and have enough information plus knowledge of the standard language to write what you're wanting.
然后也许我们可以，你知道，谈谈更多关于一些工具的事情，我认为随着底层LLM的演变，这些工具也会演变。但与之碰撞的事情对人们来说可能是显而易见的，但对我来说并不直观，我想，就像我在概念层面上知道它，但不知道它在实践中是如何工作的。但你说的例子，我说的例子都或多或少地共享了这一点：你可以获取整个文件或文件的一大部分，并拥有足够的信息加上对标准语言的了解来编写你想要的东西。
Right? So a unit test is a known concept. How to write a unit test harness in, you know, whatever go or C++ is known, um, in the training data that the model was tuned on. And then giving the context around your function call that you're refactoring or your thing, that's all known. And so what we're staying under here is the context length limit. What doesn't work or hasn't worked for me is anytime you start asking a more wide ranging question in a big code base and say, hey, can you refactor all instances
对吧？所以单元测试是一个已知的概念。如何在，你知道，任何Go或C++中编写单元测试工具是已知的，在模型经过微调的训练数据中。然后提供你正在重构的函数调用或你的东西周围的上下文，那都是已知的。所以我们在这里保持在上下文长度限制之下。什么不起作用或对我不起作用的是任何时候你开始在一个大型代码库中提出更广泛的问题，并说，嘿，你能重构所有实例吗
where this function does this thing and I want it to do that instead. And the reason it falls off a cliff is even cause it sounds the same as this, highlight this code and move it to a function is it doesn't sort of intuitively do the mapping yet of class definitions and all of this stuff. And so then it can't fit it in its context.
这个函数做这件事，我想要它改为做那个。它之所以从悬崖上掉下来，是因为即使它听起来和“高亮这段代码并将其移动到函数”一样，它还没有直观地进行类定义和所有这些东西的映射。所以它无法将其放入上下文中。
So it literally doesn't know about it because it's not in its training data and it's not in its context window. Therefore, it just doesn't exist. And so it ends up generating fake places. It's not sure where it's called and it sort of goes off the rails and you end up having to revert back, which is a big tip, revert back all the code changes it does because it just makes a mess. Yeah, that's a great call out. Like, yeah, if you're going to do anything big,
所以它实际上不知道它，因为它不在训练数据中，也不在上下文窗口中。因此，它根本不存在。所以它最终生成了虚假的地方。它不确定它在哪里被调用，它有点脱轨了，你最终不得不回滚，这是一个大提示，回滚它所做的所有代码更改，因为它只会把事情搞砸。是的，这是一个很好的提醒。就像，是的，如果你要做任何大的事情，
definitely git commit first so that you can easily undo it. Okay, so we talked about different things we've done with it, why you should learn this if you're not already. We'll jump into how it works. There are several different ways that you could use these tools. The most obvious is the VS Code integration or pick any ID. VS Code is probably there's already some kind of autocomplete there and this just makes it a lot better. You know, the one that they're really pushing,
一定要先git commit，这样你就可以轻松撤销它。好的，所以我们谈到了我们用它做的不同事情，如果你还没学会，为什么要学习这个。我们将跳到它是如何工作的。你可以通过几种不同的方式使用这些工具。最明显的是VS Code集成或选择任何IDE。VS Code可能已经有某种自动补全功能，而这只是让它好得多。你知道，他们真正推动的那个，
you know, at Microsoft is Copilot, which is their solution. And Copilot is sort of like an intermediary between you and several different options. So you can actually choose to use Claude or use the Google Gemini or OpenAI, you know, ChachiBT. So CoPilot isn't itself an AI or an LLM, it's just handling that in between step. And so with CoPilot, if you type and you stop typing for a second or two it'll do a suggestion. I think you can also force a suggestion with a key although I don't remember what it is. But if you hit command I then it will open up in place a little chat window. So you can select a block of text, hit
你知道，在微软是Copilot，这是他们的解决方案。Copilot有点像你和几个不同选项之间的中介。所以你实际上可以选择使用Claude或使用Google Gemini或OpenAI，你知道，ChatGPT。所以Copilot本身不是一个AI或LLM，它只是处理那个中间步骤。所以有了Copilot，如果你打字并停止打字一两秒钟，它就会给出一个建议。我想你也可以用一个键强制执行建议，虽然我不记得是什么键了。但如果你按command I，它就会在原地打开一个小聊天窗口。所以你可以选择一块文本，按
command I and say what is this doing? Like you don't even have to ask something that would require a modification. You can say like, what is this code doing? Or, hey, put this in its own function, or et cetera, et cetera. And it might just talk to you right there in line with the whole dialogue that you could dismiss.
command I并说这是在做什么？就像你甚至不需要问需要修改的问题。你可以说，这段代码在做什么？或者，嘿，把它放在它自己的函数里，或者等等等等。它可能会直接在那里与你对话，进行你可以关闭的整个对话。
Or it will make some code changes and give you the opportunity to accept or reject its suggestion. The other big way that people are using these tools is through the command line. So Claude code is a command line interface. You basically go to the root of your source code in a terminal, type, I think it's Claude code, and it starts up a little engine, it does some work, and then it gives you this pretty cool cursors-based terminal interface
或者它会做一些代码更改，并让你有机会接受或拒绝它的建议。人们使用这些工具的另一种主要方式是通过命令行。所以Claude code是一个命令行界面。你基本上在终端中进入源代码的根目录，输入，我想是Claude code，它会启动一个小引擎，它做一些工作，然后它给你这个非常酷的基于光标的终端界面，
where you can ask questions, it will show you diffs, it'll apply changes, etc. So that is the other kind of main way that people use it. And there's another sort of access to this which is do you want to run locally or in the cloud? By default, you know, all the tools we just mentioned run in the cloud, however there are open source versions for running either locally or running in your own land. So you know you might have an LLM running in your company on your VPN and you might want to use that instead of all
你可以在那里提问，它会向你展示差异，它会应用更改，等等。所以这是人们使用它的另一种主要方式。还有另一种访问方式，就是你想在本地运行还是在云端运行？默认情况下，你知道，我们刚才提到的所有工具都在云端运行，但是有开源版本可以在本地运行或在你自己的局域网中运行。所以你知道，你可能在你的公司VPN上运行一个LLM，你可能想使用那个而不是所有
the public ones. And so for that there's a bunch of options. There's Roo, R-O-O, there's Klein, C-L-I-N-E, there's probably a bunch of other ones. But these ones will run either models locally or at an IP address that you specify. Yeah, so I guess like, tactically, I thought you were gonna pitch your orange pie. That's a great idea. I think a couple of things. If you're going to run it in the cloud, just beware of pricing so you can get surprised bill if you're on a pay-per-usage. So don't just sort of, this happened. So my daughter and one of her cousins, they were like playing around making code and trying to, you know, generate an RPG.
公共的那些。所以为此有很多选择。有Roo，R-O-O，有Klein，C-L-I-N-E，可能还有很多其他的。但这些会运行本地模型或你指定的IP地址上的模型。是的，所以我想，在战术上，我以为你会推销你的Orange Pi。那是个好主意。我想有几件事。如果你要在云端运行它，只要注意定价，所以如果你是按使用量付费，你可能会收到意想不到的账单。所以不要只是，这发生了。所以我的女儿和她的一个表亲，她们就像在玩耍，编写代码并试图，你知道，生成一个RPG。
And it said, oh, the best way to do that is just like make an interface that asks chat GPT. And so it was like, here's how to get your chat GPT token and put your token in. And then they were just basically making an app that would have had their chat GPT token in it. And if they had, which they didn't, a credit card associated to their account, and distributed this game, everybody in the world would have just been like hitting their token, right? To like ask, could have been a bad situation.
它说，哦，最好的方法就是做一个界面，询问ChatGPT。所以它就像，这是如何获取你的ChatGPT令牌并放入你的令牌。然后她们基本上是在制作一个会在其中包含她们的ChatGPT令牌的应用。如果她们有，她们没有，一个与她们账户关联的信用卡，并分发了这个游戏，世界上的每个人都会像在点击她们的令牌，对吧？去问，这可能是一个糟糕的情况。
But to avoid that kind of like surprise billing, I mean, I think you can get subscriptions from a lot of these or, you know, things that tools will help you limit. But I also think it's instructive to run a local one, even if it's not as good, just to kind of understand, you know, what's going on and be familiar with the tooling. And to clarify what Jason said, it isn't that these tools sort of like, I think the open source version of cloud code is AIDER, A-I-D-E-R is the same kind of thing
但为了避免那种意想不到的账单，我是说，我认为你可以从很多这些服务中获得订阅，或者，你知道，工具会帮助你限制的东西。但我还认为运行一个本地的很有启发性，即使它没那么好，只是为了了解，你知道，发生了什么并熟悉这些工具。为了澄清杰森所说的，并不是这些工具有点像，我认为Claude code的开源版本是AIDER，A-I-D-E-R是同样的事情，
versus a VS code extension. They won't run your LLM, you run one, you know, yourself in sort of like an engine like Olamma or something else and you download a model, you start up the server and then it sort of talks to your local server. But again, this is great understanding of how these services would work, how you would a model, you start up the server, and then it sort of talks to your local server. But again, this is great understanding of how these services would work,
而不是VS Code扩展。它们不会运行你的LLM，你自己运行一个，你知道，在像Ollama或其他东西这样的引擎中，你下载一个模型，你启动服务器，然后它有点像与你的本地服务器对话。但同样，这是对这些服务如何工作、你如何部署它们、你如何本地运行它们的很好的理解。
how you would deploy them, how you would run them locally. And there definitely are coding-tuned models that are reasonably small, run reasonably fast enough for you to sort of like try it, get the experience, and have some of this stuff sort of not cost an arm and a leg. So even on my MacBook Airs, I can run the Quinn, I think it's the 3.5 or 2.5, I guess the Quinn 2.5 Coder tuned one isn't super big. And I can run it locally is fast enough to hook up to one of these things
而且绝对有针对编码调整的模型，它们足够小，运行速度足够快，让你尝试，获得经验，并让这些东西中的一些不会花费一大笔钱。所以即使在我的MacBook Air上，我也可以运行Quinn，我想是3.5或2.5，我猜Quinn 2.5 Coder调整过的那个不是特别大。我可以本地运行它，速度足够快，可以连接到这些东西中的一个，
to sort of get the experience and sort of try it out without any sort of like credit card information needed. Yeah, that makes a ton of sense. Another one that actually just speaking on the financial side, it is in the cloud but it's completely free is Amazon Q. And that's another one to check out if budget is a concern. But as Patrick said, with all these cloud ones, you are uploading your source code to them and so you really have to trust them. And in a corporate setting that might not be an option, but running locally is almost certainly an option.
从而获得经验并尝试一下，而不需要任何信用卡信息。是的，这非常有意义。另一个实际上在财务方面，它在云端但完全免费的是Amazon Q。如果你担心预算，这是另一个值得查看的。但正如帕特里克所说，对于所有这些云端工具，你都在将源代码上传给它们，所以你真的必须信任它们。在企业环境中，这可能不是一个选择，但本地运行几乎肯定是一个选择。
I have a friend who they don't give them administrator access to their own computer. That to me is like, I feel like I have very few things. You know, I don't need a big monitor. I don't need a desk that goes up and down. I mean, I like having a desk that goes up and down. But if I don't have admin access to my laptop, I think that might be a deal breaker for me. More career advice. If you're looking for a job, it's okay if it's in South Dakota, but you need admin access to your office. Yeah, I would not ask that during the interview.
我有一个朋友，他们不给他们自己电脑的管理员权限。对我来说，就像，我觉得我几乎没有什么东西。你知道，我不需要大显示器。我不需要可以升降的桌子。我是说，我喜欢有一张可以升降的桌子。但如果我没有笔记本电脑的管理员权限，我想那对我来说可能是个交易破坏者。更多的职业建议。如果你在找工作，如果它在南达科他州没关系，但你需要办公室的管理员权限。是的，我不会在面试中问那个。
That was probably, I don't know, it could go either way. At least they know you're serious. At least they know you're serious. On these sort of interfaces, sort of like chatting, highlight selection, tab completion, which one would you say is where you think today, if you could only have one of them, which one do you think delivers the most value, like where we are sitting in June of 2025? I mean, definitely the tab completion. You know, I think that, uh, at least in Python, it's really, really good.
那可能，我不知道，可能会有不同的结果。至少他们知道你是认真的。至少他们知道你是认真的。在这些界面上，比如聊天、高亮选择、Tab键补全，你会说哪一个是你认为今天，如果你只能拥有其中一个，哪一个你认为提供了最大的价值，就像我们在2025年6月所处的位置？我是说，绝对是Tab键补全。你知道，我认为，呃，至少在Python中，它真的真的很好。
Um, you know, often like I only have to type the first part of a line, then hit tab and you get the rest of the line for free. Um, so it's one, it's, it's hard. It's a hard question to answer because. You know, the, the answer because you know the the select You know command I thing does bigger has bigger impact like the one you talked about. I had a similar one where Oh, this is kind of interesting. So I needed to do actually also a shortest path, but the problem was
嗯，你知道，通常我只需要输入一行的第一部分，然后按Tab键，你就可以免费获得剩下的部分。嗯，所以这是一个，这是一个很难回答的问题，因为。你知道，答案是因为你知道选择，你知道command I那个东西有更大的影响，就像你谈到的那个。我有一个类似的，哦，这很有趣。所以我实际上也需要做一个最短路径，但问题是
It was not the shortest path to a destination. It was actually the shortest path to a set of destinations. And the network X library in Python doesn't have that as an option. You have to do either point to point, or you can do Floyd Warsaw, which gives you all shortest paths that would take like a year or something. So it wasn't an option. as a pass that would take like a year or something so it wasn't an option so um so what what chat gbt suggested is like why don't you make another node and have all your goal nodes point to that node with like a zero weight edge and then you could do point to point and i was like that's
它不是到目的地的最短路径。它实际上是到一组目的地的最短路径。Python中的Network X库没有这个选项。你必须做点对点，或者你可以做Floyd Warsaw，这会给你所有的最短路径，那会花一年左右的时间。所以这不是一个选项。作为一条会花一年左右的时间的路径，所以这不是一个选项。所以，嗯，所以ChatGPT建议的是，为什么你不创建另一个节点，让所有的目标节点指向那个节点，权重为零的边，然后你就可以做点对点了，我当时就想，那很
smart i was like can you do it for me and it it's like sure yeah so that is like uh that was an amazing experience right so like I feel like it's kind of apples and oranges because the tab completion makes me 10 20 percent faster but the but the um but the command i thing is kind of magical. So okay I yeah I'm both I agree with you I think is kind of magical. So, okay. Yeah, I agree with you. I think the tab completion and a little bit the highlight thing, but I think my point there, which I agree with you, today, that's where I'm getting, I think, the most speed up,
聪明，我当时想，你能为我做吗？它就像，当然可以，是的，所以这就像，呃，那是一次很棒的经历，对吧？所以就像我觉得这有点像苹果和橘子，因为Tab键补全让我快了10%到20%，但，但那个command I的东西有点神奇。所以好吧，我，我同意你的观点，我认为有点神奇。所以，好吧。是的，我同意你的观点。我认为Tab键补全和一点点高亮的东西，但我认为我的观点是，我同意你的观点，今天，这就是我获得，我认为，最大速度提升的地方，
which is sort of unexpected because it's not the key sort of demonstrable thing if you go to these websites. Like that's not what they're pitching. They're all pitching the, you tell it a high level thing and it generates magic code for you. Like that's the dream, but that's not the reality of like where I'm seeing like usefulness today
这有点出乎意料，因为它不是如果你去这些网站时那种关键的可演示的东西。就像那不是他们推销的东西。他们都在推销，你告诉它一个高层的东西，它为你生成神奇的代码。就像那是梦想，但那不是我今天看到有用性的现实，
for a variety of reasons. And I think that's partly because of what we said, it's, you know, we're already coders, we're already in there, we don't want massive things that we can't review. And then you end up with this, I always think this is funny. I type English to the LLM and it generates a bunch of code, but it's too much code for
出于各种原因。而且我认为这部分是因为我们所说的，它是，你知道，我们已经是程序员了，我们已经在那里了，我们不想要我们无法审查的大规模东西。然后你最终得到这个，我总是觉得这很有趣。我输入英语给LLM，它生成一堆代码，但代码太多了，
the reviewers to look at. So they grab all the code and ask the LLM to make English summary. And so it's just like a really inefficient transport mechanism. Wouldn't it be better if we just shared the like, anyways, it's a side, side, side, you know, ideation. But, but to your point about asking chat JVT, I think this is another really interesting thing that is very useful.
审查者无法查看。所以他们抓取所有的代码并要求LLM做一个英语总结。所以这就像一个非常低效的传输机制。如果我们只是分享那个，岂不是更好，无论如何，这是一个侧面，侧面，侧面，你知道，构思。但是，但关于询问ChatGPT的观点，我认为这是另一个非常有趣且非常有用的事情。
We sort of surprised that, but some things like those you're saying, I actually knew about that trick because you can find it in Stack Overflow or Google, which isn't that much different, but perhaps a more interesting sort of way of doing that. But those question asking things are really clutch when they come in. But I also think that's where when you get off of where there's open source or high level stuff and into
我们有点惊讶，但有些事情就像你说的那些，我实际上知道那个技巧，因为你可以在Stack Overflow或Google上找到它，这并没有什么不同，但也许是一种更有趣的方式来做这件事。但那些提问的事情在它们出现时真的很关键。但我还认为这就是当你离开开源或高层东西，进入
details about like, you know, the specifics of the kind of work that I do, or I'm sure some of the specifics of work you do, which isn't in open source, it's not in libraries, it's not common, you know, or you have some particular algorithm that's magic sauce to your stuff. None of that works. Like it all falls off the rails. It has no clue. It can't answer questions. It's too obscure and too detailed. And this is where, to your point, like domain experts either need to be trained or, you know, hired to really do that work. So like in your example, so talking about the future here, in your example where you said, hey, I need a Dykstra's, right, I have a DFS and you have Dykstra's. Like, couldn't you imagine, could you imagine a feature where, you know, in source
关于，你知道，我所做工作的具体细节，或者我相信你所做工作的一些具体细节，这些不在开源中，不在库中，不常见，你知道，或者你有一些特定的算法是你的东西的魔法酱。这些都不起作用。就像它完全脱轨了。它毫无头绪。它无法回答问题。它太晦涩、太详细了。这就是，正如你所说，领域专家要么需要被培训，要么，你知道，被雇佣来真正做这项工作。所以就像在你的例子中，所以谈论未来，在你的例子中，你说，嘿，我需要Dijkstra，对吧？我有一个DFS，你有Dijkstra。就像，你能不能想象，你能不能想象一个功能，你知道，在源代码
control, it's just that question. Like in source control is just like, hey, I need something. It's kind of like this DFS, but Dykstra is both the same API. And you check in that like one line text file. And then over time, it just gets better and better. Right, right. And if there's like a change to the language, you know, or something, you wouldn't have to worry about it. I mean, I think that's what optimizing compilers are more or less already doing. Right. You're writing a high level thing or the JIT in Python or whatever, right? Like you're writing a high level thing.
控制中，它只是那个问题。就像在源代码控制中只是，嘿，我需要某样东西。它有点像这个DFS，但Dijkstra是同一个API。你签入那个一行文本文件。然后随着时间的推移，它变得越来越好。对，对。如果语言有变化，你知道，或者什么，你就不必担心它了。我是说，我认为这就是优化编译器或多或少已经在做的事情。对吧？你正在编写一个高层的东西，或者Python中的JIT，或者其他什么，对吧？就像你正在编写一个高层的东西。
It's examining it at runtime and deciding the op codes to run on the processor. Yeah. Yeah. I think, I think that makes sense. I think, um, I think the, so then what people do, right, is they take it to his logical limit and they say, okay, well, and the logical limit there is your whole source control is really just text prompts, but I think the problem is. Um, that might be, that might happen, but it's going to be really, really far
它在运行时检查它并决定在处理器上运行的操作码。是的。是的。我认为，我认为这有道理。我认为，嗯，我认为，所以人们所做的，对吧，是他们把它带到逻辑极限，他们说，好吧，逻辑极限是你的整个源代码控制实际上只是文本提示，但我认为问题是。嗯，那可能会发生，但它会非常非常遥远
from now and people are selling it as if it's going to be really, really far from now. And people are selling it as if it's today. And so that's a bit of snake oil. Yeah. I think you get, and it's hard for me to expand upon, but when you ask for those higher level things, like where you get functions calling other functions and you just don't end up with all of the software engineering, which maybe one day is okay, but for now it's very difficult to maintain the code because you don't end up with good principles applied. It looks like
从现在开始，人们把它卖得好像它会非常非常遥远。人们把它卖得好像它是今天。所以那有点像蛇油。是的。我认为你得到，而且我很难展开，但当你要求那些更高层的东西时，就像你得到函数调用其他函数，而你最终没有得到所有的软件工程，也许有一天没关系，但现在维护代码非常困难，因为你最终没有应用好的原则。它看起来像
someone who sort of read the handbook on how to write Python, but they don't really know how to write it yet. So we sometimes bump into this with entry-level new hires. They'll just write spaghetti code as an example. And it's like, no, no, no, you can't do that. Like, but why? Well, because you're not writing it once, you're writing it more than once. Well, but you've never written it more than once. You don't know that, right?
就像是那种读过 Python 手册，但还不太会写代码的人。我们有时会在初级新员工身上遇到这种情况。他们写出的代码就像意大利面一样乱。你会说，不不不，不能这么写。他们会问，为什么？因为你写的不是一次性代码，你需要多次复用。但他们会说，你又没写过多次，你怎么知道？对吧？
Yeah. So I think these kinds of things are missing, but maybe they'll get better. I don't believe it's a static answer. Yep, yep, that makes sense. Okay, a couple of details here. If you are using Copilot, turn on the experimental mode. That basically gives you all the features of Cursor.
是的。所以我认为这些方面还有所欠缺，但也许会慢慢变好。我不认为这是一个静态的答案。没错，这很有道理。好了，这里有几个细节。如果你正在使用 Copilot，请开启实验模式。这基本上能让你获得 Cursor 的所有功能。
So, Cursor is interesting. It's a very successful company, or at least they've raised a lot of money and they have a high valuation. And the thing that they forked VS code and the thing that they did that was unique was that part of the tab completion there's also instructions to do jumps. So for example, let's say you rename a variable and you need to rename it in like 10 other places and for whatever reason you don't use find replace. It will actually jump to the you rename a variable and you need to rename it in like 10 other places and for whatever
Cursor 很有意思。它是一家非常成功的公司，至少他们筹集了大量资金，估值也很高。他们对 VS Code 进行了分支，其独特之处在于，标签页补全功能中还包含了跳转指令。例如，假设你重命名了一个变量，需要在其他 10 个地方也进行重命名，而由于某种原因你没有使用查找替换功能。它实际上会跳转到你重命名了一个变量，需要在其他 10 个地方也进行重命名，而由于某种原因你
reason you don't use find replace. It will actually jump to the next place that variables used. I think it could even jump to other files. It does that through like a tab on the right. But, but you know, it's like, it's a more holistic versus just auto complete where you're at, like it'll auto complete somewhere else. And and copilot with experimental mode does the same thing. Uh, people ask like, Oh, why did cursor, you know, do this and co-pilot didn't.
没有使用查找替换功能。它实际上会跳转到该变量被使用的下一个位置。我想它甚至可以跳转到其他文件。它是通过右侧的一个标签页来实现的。但你知道，这是一种更全面的方式，而不仅仅是你当前位置的自动补全，它甚至可以在其他地方进行自动补全。Copilot 在实验模式下也能做到这一点。人们会问，哦，为什么 Cursor 做了这个，而 Copilot 没有做？
And the answer is they had it. They have it in the experimental mode. They're just not fast enough, which is kind of interesting. Uh, you know, rolling it out. Um, but, uh, you know, cursor is another way to go. And it's a little different experience because you're kind of jumping around when you hit tab. So you basically hit tab once to jump to the location
答案是他们其实有这个功能。他们在实验模式里就有。只是他们推进的速度不够快，这挺有意思的。嗯，你知道，推广它。但是，你知道，Cursor 是另一种选择。它的体验有点不同，因为当你按下 Tab 键时，你会跳转到不同位置，
and then tab again to actually execute the auto-complete. They can get a little confusing because if the auto-complete is right there at the cursor, it's only one tab, otherwise it's two tabs, but you get used to it. You could even do the one tab to get you there and then change what the auto-complete wants to do slightly, et cetera.
然后再按一次 Tab 键来执行自动补全。这可能会让人有点困惑，因为如果自动补全就在光标处，只需要按一次 Tab，否则就需要按两次，但你习惯了就好。你甚至可以按一次 Tab 跳转过去，然后稍微修改一下自动补全的内容，等等。
You got me thinking with that is, you're talking about almost like a new paradigm, right? So you start with just a new paradigm, right? So you start with just a text editor, then we end up with more of an IDE, an integrated development environment where you can run code and do debugging and it's like all built in. And then what you're talking about is sort of like a large but incremental step further where like, you know, today you would be very frustrated if you were getting jumped around
你让我想到，你谈论的几乎是一种新的范式，对吧？所以你从一个简单的文本编辑器开始，然后我们最终得到了更像 IDE 的集成开发环境，你可以在其中运行代码、进行调试，一切都是内置的。而你所谈论的，是一种更大但渐进的进步，比如，你知道，今天如果你在文件之间跳来跳去，你会感到非常沮丧，
files but you're kind of a different view, a sort of guided, you're sort of working together with somebody else to move through the code in a way. And I wonder if that's part of the missing link for doing these sort of larger code block things is having it to where, I guess it's just CPU and eventually it'll get faster or just GPU. But, but not just generating the code, but also giving you like generating
但你现在有了一种不同的视角，一种引导式的视角，你就像是在和别人一起协作，以某种方式在代码中穿梭。我想知道这是否是实现这些大型代码块功能的缺失环节，也许只是 CPU 的问题，最终它会变得更快，或者只是 GPU 的问题。但不仅仅是生成代码，还要为你提供，比如生成
sample data coming in, sample data coming out, and then offering you, do you want to adjust the sample data for you might, you could do that with the unit test, right? But you're not going to go write unit tests. Like that's too much thrashing back and forth, back and forth. But if you imagine almost an interactive, here's a block of code flow I wrote. Here's how data comes in. Here's how data comes out.
输入样本数据，输出样本数据，然后询问你，是否要为你调整样本数据？你当然可以用单元测试来做，对吧？但你不会去写单元测试。那太折腾了，来回反复。但如果你想象一个交互式的流程，我写了一个代码块。这是输入数据，这是输出数据。
I've compiled it. I've run it, you know, to show this is what's actually happening and actually kind of rotating around. Like you said a bit, you have your text prompts, but then you also have the code and the output as sort of a, just a fundamentally different paradigm of how you interact with it. I don't know how to go build that, but I wonder if, like you're saying,
我已经编译并运行了它，你知道，展示了实际发生的情况，并进行了一些调整。就像你说的，你有文本提示，但你也有代码和输出，这是一种本质上完全不同的交互范式。我不知道该怎么去构建它，但我好奇，就像你说的，
if we're sort of seeing the beginnings of that, this sort of extension, first you're trying to integrate where we're at, and then you're trying to go past, right? You're trying to come to the next level thing where it's not just a blind text box, it's a cooperative way of doing programming with a much more powerful. Tool plus compiler.
我们是否正在见证它的萌芽，这种扩展，首先你试图整合我们所处的位置，然后你试图超越它，对吧？你试图达到下一个层次，它不仅仅是一个盲目的文本框，而是一种与更强大的工具加编译器进行协作的编程方式。
Yeah. Yeah, totally. Um, but that doesn't help anyone you're doing, you're doing actual actual tools. Sorry. No, it's fine. No. One other thing that, that I think is getting more popular are having these tools try to improve your code base.
是的，完全同意。嗯，但这帮不上那些正在使用实际工具的人。抱歉。不，没关系。还有一件事，我认为正变得越来越流行，那就是让这些工具尝试改进你的代码库。
So it's like every day they ask it like, hey, what can we do to make this code better? And then it auto generates a PR. There's been some really funny situations with that. But I mean, some of these things were like, if half the time you just close the PR and the other half of the time it's good that's still fine like you didn't really waste that much time on the 50% that weren't useful so so yeah I think that's another direction things could go in so call to action here is pretty clear I mean you should try these tools for so many different reasons. If your company doesn't allow it, you can
所以就像每天都问它，嘿，我们能做些什么来让这段代码更好？然后它会自动生成一个 PR。这出现过一些非常有趣的情况。但我的意思是，其中一些情况是，如果你有一半时间直接关闭 PR，而另一半时间它很有用，那也没关系，因为你在那 50% 没用的工作上并没有浪费太多时间。所以是的，我认为这是事情发展的另一个方向。所以这里的行动号召很明确，我的意思是，你应该出于各种原因尝试这些工具。如果你的公司不允许，你可以
run the tool locally. It won't be as good, but still pretty good. If the company doesn't allow you to run it locally, we told you what to do. You got to find that company in South Dakota that will let you run it. Yeah, you work at the potato chip factory. That's what your advice was. That's right. Yeah, go work for the potato chip factory. Um, but, uh, you know, there's really no excuse for not trying these tools out, becoming adept at them. And I think you should advertise when you are adept at them because it does, it is for now a differentiator.
在本地运行该工具。虽然效果不会那么好，但仍然相当不错。如果公司不允许你在本地运行，我们已经告诉你该怎么做了。你得找到南达科他州那家允许你运行它的公司。是的，你在薯片工厂工作。这就是你的建议。没错。是的，去为薯片工厂工作。嗯，但是，你知道，真的没有理由不去尝试这些工具，并变得精通它们。而且我认为你应该在你精通它们时进行宣传，因为目前这确实是一个差异化优势。
Another episode. Another episode, another father's day. Um, did you, uh, did you spend time with your father on father's day? You did? Yeah, me too. It was kind of nice. It's like a, I guess it's like a father's square day for them. A grandfather's day.
又一期节目。又一期节目，又一个父亲节。嗯，你，你有没有在父亲节陪你的父亲？你有吗？是的，我也是。感觉挺好的。我想这就像是他们的父亲平方节。祖父节。
What? Yeah. No, I'm just kidding. Yes. Pretty mind blowing. No, we did. We did. I hope everyone out there had a great weekend, whether you, whatever you did that weekend.
什么？是的。不，我开玩笑的。是的。太令人震惊了。不，我们确实陪了。我希望外面的每个人都度过了一个愉快的周末，无论你那个周末做了什么。
I hope everyone's having a good time out there. I really appreciate the feedback. We got some emails, some Discord messages about how to get a job. And so that inspired us to spend a good 20 minutes talking about it. So your feedback, your questions, your emails, your follows on Twitter that I don't get.
我希望每个人在外都过得开心。我真的很感谢大家的反馈。我们收到了一些电子邮件和 Discord 消息，询问如何找到工作。所以这启发了我们花 20 分钟来讨论这个问题。所以你们的反馈、你们的问题、你们的电子邮件、你们在 Twitter 上的关注，虽然我没看到，
All of that is greatly appreciated. And we do take it seriously and we've made all episodes, parts of episodes based on that. We're here to try and help you all out as much as we can. Thanks everyone. Catch y'all later. Music by Eric Barndaler Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share-Alike 2.0 license. You are free to share, copy, distribute,
所有这些都非常感谢。我们非常重视，并根据这些内容制作了所有剧集或剧集片段。我们在这里尽我们所能帮助大家。谢谢大家。回头见。音乐由 Eric Barndaler 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、
transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
传播该作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须注明我和 Patrick 的署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。